pour mes chers collègues bonjour
messieurs les ministres madame la
Présidente la séance est ouverte le
compte rendu analytique de la précédente
séance a été distribuée y a-t-il des
observations je n'en vois pas le
procès-verbal est donc adopté sous les
réserves d'usage l'ordre du jour rappel
la suite de la discussion du projet de
loi de financement rectificative de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'amendement 33 08 au sein de
l'article 9 article 9 je donne la parole
à la présidente madame de roche
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vous
souhaite la bienvenue pour une journée
que sans doute sera aussi dynamique que
la soirée que nous avons connue hier et
donc madame la Présidente en application
de l'article 44 alinéa 6 du règlement la
Commission demande sur cet article 9 la
priorité d'examen de vote sur
l'amendement des rapporteurs le 21 38
pour préciser il s'agit du maintien 60
ans de l'âge de la retraite pour
incapacité permanente sujet que nous
avons largement développé en commission
je précise que cette priorité ne fait
tomber aucun amendement
nous reprendrons
s'améliore de changer nous reprendrons
ensuite le cours normal de nos débats
très bien merci madame la Présidente je
suis donc saisie d'une demande de
priorité de la Commission sur
l'amendement
2138 afin qu'il soit appelé et mis au
voie immédiatement selon l'article 44
alinéa 6 de notre règlement la priorité
est de droit quand elle est demandée par
la Commission saisie au fond sauf
opposition du gouvernement messieurs les
ministres quelle est la vie du
gouvernement sur cette demande de
priorité merci madame la présidente
madame la Présidente de la Commission
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs comme
depuis le début de ce débat est
traditionnellement le gouvernement ne
s'oppose pas aux demandes de priorité de
la Commission et s'en remet au Sénat
puisque le gouvernement ne s'y oposs pas
la priorité et donc ordonnée
nous nous sommes en train oui oui madame
la Présidente il y a pas de souci nous
sommes en train de distribuer je vais
attendre que la distribution soit
finalisée de l'amendement donc 21 38
avant qu'il ne soit présenté
par nos rapports
monsieur le rapporteur j'attends
simplement que
là voilà que l'amendement soit distribué
vous souhaitez simplement que le
rapporteur soit prêt
c'est bon je pense qu'il a été distribué
à tous les sénateurs présents monsieur
le rapporteur pour présentation de cet
amendement merci effectivement
nous sommes très attachés à cette
modification proposée par Elisabeth
Doisneau et moi-même à la commission des
affaires sociales pour faire en sorte
que la capacité
permanente soit dans le cas des
retraites anticipées pris en compte en
restant si possible dans le droit actuel
effectivement elle s'applique des 60 ans
actuellement lorsque vous avez une
incapacité permanente un minimum auteur
de 20% ou si vous êtes entre 10 et 20%
d'incapacité permanente et vous êtes
exposé un certain nombre d'années à
savoir 17 ans pour certains facteurs
d'autres facteurs n'ont pas durées
d'exposition au risque vous pouvez
bénéficier d'une retraite anticipée deux
ans avant l'âge légal donc à partir de
60 ans donc la Commission à réfléchir à
ce dispositif ou lorsqu'on un effort
supplémentaire aux gens
ils risquent effectivement d'être plus
utilisé qu'actuellement et c'est vrai
que il est actuellement insuffisamment
utilisé c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous souhaitons pointer cette
spécificité du doigt vis-à-vis du
gouvernement ça rentre dans la logique
dans la logique qui nous a animé de
faire en sorte que nous puissions
répondre aux préoccupations de nos
concitoyens ils l'ont largement exprimé
dans la rue et ça c'est me semble-t-il
un élément de réponse tout à fait
déterminant c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes attachés à ce à
cette proposition monsieur le ministre
pour la pour laquelle nous n'avons pas
encore obtenu
satisfaction c'est que nous n'avons pas
été suffisamment
convaincant un argument supplémentaire
mais c'est peut-être une argustine
budgétaire c'est que c'est une mesure
qui relève de la branche ATMP de la
sécurité sociale et non pas de la
branche vieillesse et dans le cas de
l'équilibre de cette réforme il ne la
pénalise pas néanmoins néanmoins c'est
une dépense supplémentaire sur les
comptes publics soyons tout à fait clair
dans ce type de dispositif mais ça nous
paraît être un élément qui peut être
largement partagé sur ses bancs où on a
eu suffisamment peut-être de division
jusqu'à présent où on peut être
peut-être se rassembler sur ce type de
dispositif merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur
puis-je avoir la vie du gouvernement
peut-être un mot d'abord pour dire que
je donne acte bien volontiers à monsieur
le rapporteur que la dépense que
susciterait que créerait une telle
disposition c'est l'été adoptée n'est
pas une dépense qui concerne ce qu'on
appelle les bornes du système de
retraite puisque c'est une dépense qui
serait portée par la branche accident du
travail et maladie professionnelle vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur ça me
déséquilibre pas le système de retraite
est donc ça ne controvient pas à
l'objectif de retour à l'équilibre du
système de retraite il n'empêche que
c'est une dépense publique c'est une
dépense sociale portée par la bronche
ATMP que nous évaluons entre 250 et 260
millions d'euros par an le gouvernement
et c'est une évaluation je précise les
choses brutes pour donner suite à mon
raisonnement le gouvernement a fait un
choix différent de celui que propose
votre commission des affaires sociales
nous avons fait le choix de maintenir
dans cette logique de relèvement des
seuils à 62 ans le départ pour
incapacité permanente mais en
élargissant de manière extrêmement
importante les critères d'accès à cette
retraite anticipée pour incapacité Perm
je ne donne qu'un exemple pour illustrer
le propos actuellement pour bénéficier
d'un départ anticipé au titre de
l'incapacité permanente il faut
justifier d'une exposition à des
facteurs de pénibilité justifiant de la
situation d'incapacité pendant 17 ans
nous avons prévu dans le texte que nous
vous proposons que cette exposition soit
ramenée de 17 à 50 de la même manière
nous avons prévu je l'ai évoqué hier je
crois le fait que ce départ anticipé
puisse être de droit pour les assurer
qui ont un taux d'incapacité reconnu
supérieur ou égal à 20% sans passer par
une seconde procédure médicale
considérons que la reconnaissance d'un
tome égale ou supérieur à 20%, vaut
d'une certaine manière avis médical
permanent si
nous suivons votre commission cela veut
dire que nous supprimons les
assouplissements que nous apportons aux
règles et nous supprimons vous
supprimeriez pardon le passage de 17 à
50 expositions pour rester sur 17 ans
d'exposition mais avec en contrepartie
un départ plutôt c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit bien instant que la dépense que nous
estimons entre 250 et 260 millions
d'euros est une dépense brute puisqu'il
faudrait tenir compte aussi de la
moindre dépense supprimée du fait de la
suppression pardon pour se répétitions
des assouplissements que nous proposons
pour toutes ces raisons vous l'avez
compris la vie du gouvernement et
défavorable je dis en ayant bien en tête
que c'est un amendement qui a été adopté
par votre commission mais pour ces deux
principes à la fois le fait que nous
ayons choisi une méthode différente par
assouplissement des critères plutôt que
par bouger de l'âge nous ne pouvons que
nous opposer j'ajoute que nous sommes
dans une logique aussi de lisibilité sur
les soldages à partir desquels on peut
faire valoir le droit à tel ou tel
départ et que c'est une raison
supplémentaire pour nous de donner cet
avis défavorable
monsieur le rapporteur vous souhaitiez
apporter des précisions
monsieur le ministre la durée
d'exposition pour certains facteurs de
risque pour d'autres on voit bien qu'il
y a une différence elle peut être prise
par décret donc rien ne vous empêche de
prendre le décret
rien ne vous empêche de prendre le
décret derrière pour faire en sorte que
notre proposition soit élargi
effectivement à cette réduction de la
durée d'exposition quand la commission
pluridique disciplinaire qui serait
effectivement pour ceux qui ont plus de
20 % la capacité qui ne serait pas
réunies il y aura un passage
systématique d'incapacité à 20% sur une
retraite anticipée franchement c'est là
aussi une avancée que vous pouvez faire
quel que soit le vote du Sénat donc je
pense que nos mesures sont
complémentaires et j'inciterai mes
collègues bien sûr les soutenir merci
merci pour expliquer de votre madame la
Présidente rossignol
merci madame la Présidente bonjour chers
collègues
cet amendement a beaucoup de vertus la
première c'est qu'il protège le droit au
départ en retraite à 60 ans des salariés
en incapacité permanente et la deuxième
c'est qu'il ne fait tomber aucune aucun
amendement on n'en voudrait que des
comme ça pour autant de remarques quand
même par rapport aux propos du ministre
qui dit que c'est amendement va
augmenter les dépenses c'est pas tout à
fait vrai c'est pas une dépense nouvelle
c'est une moindre économie sur votre
projet de réforme des retraites ce qui
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose et
c'est un transfert de charge de
l'assurance vieillesse vers la branche
accident du travail maladie
professionnelle donc il faut être qu'on
soit plus précis dans notre manière de
nous exprimer pour pas faire croire aux
gens qui nous regardent et ils sont
quand même très nombreux je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué vous aussi que nos
amendements seraient des amendements
irresponsables enfin nous allons en
espèces est une du rapporteur serait des
amendements irresponsables qui ne
prendrait pas en compte
le nécessaire équilibre des dépenses
publiques la deuxième chose que que je
voulais dire c'est que en fait c'est
assez diabolique le piège dans lequel
vous essayez de nous mettre monsieur le
ministre c'est le chantage permanent si
vous votez l'amendement ça varie alors
vous supprimerez des mesures importantes
sur les deux exposition et ce chantage
là on peut pas l'accepter donc nous
allons voter l'amendement Savary et nous
dénonçons votre chantage
merci Madame Ferré pour explication de
vote
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre effectivement combien de le
préciser ma collègue nous allons voter
cet amendement cet amendement qui va de
dans le bon sens car nous avons dénoncé
depuis le début de ce débat
le reportage qui nous disons sans cesse
ces deux ans de plus pour tout le monde
quel que soit la situation ceux qui
partaient à 62 vont partir à 64 c'est
ceux qui partaient à 60 pour partir à 62
cet amendement propose de maintenir ce
possibilité donc de départ à 60 ans ça
va vraiment dans le bon sens ça
reconnaît les la pénibilité et la
situation parfois extrêmement difficile
pour celles et ceux qui relèvent de ce
dispositif et non ça n'est pas une
dépense nouvelle puisque on maintient ce
qui est organisé aujourd'hui donc voilà
je voulais dire que notre groupe allait
voter favorablement cet amendement merci
chers collègues la parole est donnée au
président carucci
le ministre
franchement après
comment dire le spectacle un peu
désolant ces derniers jours lorsqu'on
rentre sur des amendements un peu
construit
je souhaite vivement que le gouvernement
face à un effort
vous ne pouvez pas considérer que
l'équilibre de votre texte même si vous
avez déjà fait des efforts en début de
débat sur les retraites mais
reconnaissons que
il faut encore des avancées
si vous souhaitez vouloir travailler
avec le Sénat avec l'ensemble du Sénat
il faut accepter des modifications on a
hier malgré le désordre généralisé on a
hier beaucoup insisté sur l'usure sur
les carrières très difficiles sur les
gens qui souffraient en fin de carrière
et qui avait besoin de partir plus tôt
l'amendement du rapporteur vous permet
de dire que l'allongement que vous
souhaitez de la durée ou le report de
l'âge ne sont pas les mêmes pour tout le
monde et que clairement lorsque
quelqu'un n'est plus en situation de
travailler il faut pas le lui imposer
alors je reconnais bien volontiers que
quand vous prenez des mesures comme
celle là forcément
ça a un coût mais oui bien sûr monsieur
le ministre mais la justice et le fait
de pouvoir présenter aux Français une
réforme en disant elle est difficile
pour tout le monde parce qu'il faut
sauver les comptes publics le compte
public sur l'équilibre des retraites
mais quand même le gouvernement le Sénat
sont attentifs au fait de dire nous
savons qu'il y a des gens pour lesquels
ça n'est pas possible et nous prenons
les mesures nécessaires pour trouver des
solutions n'hésitez pas à Monsieur le
Ministre à les prendre avec nous
[Applaudissements]
madame ponce pour explication de vote
oui merci ma présidente alors nous aussi
nous avions des arguments construits
mais ils ont tous été frappés par
l'article 40 mais là je vois
qu'effectivement vous le contournez donc
par contre comme tous mes collègues je
le soutiendrai
c'est que qu'une des mesures de
transfert de bronches transfert aux
autres branches de des effets de la
réforme là on parle de la TMP mais c'est
pas les seuls et il y a quand même des
transferts invisibilisés sur la maladie
sur la CNAM sur le chômage sur le RSA
sur les minima sociaux tout ça c'est
invisibilisé là comme vous voulez mettre
cela vous êtes obligé de rendre visible
un des transferts et je pense qu'ils
sont plutôt à hauteur de 5 milliards que
de 200 millions alors monsieur le
ministre vous dites bon le rapporteur
vous l'a dit les mesures
d'accompagnement et bien vous allez les
préserver parce que je pense que c'est
le seul souci que vous avez pour rendre
favorable votre avis vous allez les le
faire par décret mais moi je voudrais
revenir sur les 3 milliards
que vous avez mis comme mesure
d'accompagnement sur l'incapacité
permanente à tort puisque c'était un
maintien donc là nous avons trois
milliards de marge de manœuvre pour
mettre toutes les mesures qu'on voudrait
ajouter 250 à 300 millions là pour le
coup ça tient bien et j'ai jamais eu de
réponse c'est ce qui m'étonne c'est que
la Commission y compris des finances
y compris de la commission sociale
depuis le temps que je dis que il y a 3
milliards sans qui sont indument mis sur
les mesures d'accompagnement qui de fait
alors après vous les laisse plus qu'à 3
milliards personne ce soir penché sur ça
que font ces 3 milliards moi j'estime en
début de cette réunion que nous avons la
démarche de manœuvre pour 3 milliards
sans de mesures d'atténuation de la
brutalité de votre de votre
réforme alors effectivement on peut être
que pour nous l'aurions proposé très
d'ailleurs je l'avais dit
très très naturellement mais nous
n'avons pas les mêmes moyens que vous
merci chers
oui monsieur le ministre moi j'ai
monsieur le rapporteur
je reprends un des arguments que j'avais
développé avant-hier je crois pourquoi
ne mettons pas à profit ce projet de loi
puisque vous cherchez combien de le dire
ma collègue atténuée certains nombres
d'effets
des conséquences qu'il aura pour faire
en sorte que toutes les personnes qui
sont qualifiées de personnes handicapées
puissent avoir un droit de départ à la
retraite à 60 ans certaines restent à 62
en fonction
[Musique]
soit on est en âge soit on est en
incapacité je ne sais pas très bien je
n'arrive pas à comprendre d'autant que
ces personnes-là ne travaillent pas et
bénéficient d'autres sources de revenus
qui sont prises sur d'autres chapitres
budgétaires de nos comptes de la
sécurité sociale
si chers collègues docteur chassant pour
explication de vote
monsieur le ministre monsieur du
ministre de la prison mes chers
collègues donc moi je suis bien sûr tout
à fait d'accord avec cet amendement
c'est une avancée importante pour les
personnes qui ont travaillé dans un
secteur de pénibilité puisque passer de
d'incapacité de 20% à 10% de d'accident
après maladie professionnelle ou
accident de travail pour voir le
retraite à 60 ans c'est comme une
amélioration très importante pour nos
concitoyens comme une exposition qui
passe de 17 ans à 5 ans donc je pense
que c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
bien pour nous nos concitoyens je pense
qu'il faut le dire
certains disent que il y a beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui regardent cette CD
bas et bien là on peut dire que c'est
une avancée sociale importante et aussi
la réparation des dommages subis par les
assurés exposés à la BD pénibilité au
cours de leur carrière puisque il y a un
maintien 60 ans de l'âge minimum de
départ de retraite anticipée pour
incapacité permanente donc je pense
qu'il faut féliciter donc
leur rapporteur et des rapporteurs qui
ont mis en place cet amendement et
j'espère que le gouvernement
pourra donner satisfaction merci
merci Madame Goulet pour explication de
vote
monsieur le ministre moi je veux très
évidemment cet amendement avec
enthousiasme je remercie d'ailleurs les
rapporteurs au nom de la commission de
l'avoir déposée et je voudrais dire au
ministre qu'il fasse confiance au Sénat
parce que vous voyez que sur tous ces
bancs nous sommes nous sommes d'accord
avec cet amendement et que par ailleurs
l'aspect financier n'a pas été relevé
puisque vous pouvez aussi faire
confiance à la commission des finances
pour stopper l'article 40 quand on en a
besoin donc je pense que c'est un très
bon amendement que c'est un très bon
signal aussi les collègues l'ont dit et
donc nous voterons cet amendement
merci chers collègues monsieur rénal
pour explication de vote
puisque une explication de vote encore
que je le mets dans ce évidemment dans
la dedans c'est une explication du
président de la commission des finances
sur le fait que on nous regarde
maintenant et on travaille sur un
amendement clairement article 40
et comment le président de la commission
des finances peut-il laisser passer un
amendement partie 40 et d'autres ont dit
mais nous amendements sont pas passés
alors je voudrais d'abord remercier le
ministre Attal
parce que si il n'y a pas d'article 40
aujourd'hui sur cet amendement c'est
parce que le ministre Attal dans ça des
G a ouvert dans des propos
légèrement ambigu mais permettant
d'ouvrir il a dit qu'il ouvrait qui
pensait qu'il y avait un intérêt pour
une discussion sur ce point sans
cependant prendre une position
d'ouverture formelle sur ce sujet je
vous rappelle que pour pouvoir dépasser
l'article 40 il faut qu'il y ait une
intention du gouvernement est-ce que ça
c'était une intention du gouvernement
on peut les juristes pourraient s'en
emparer on va le dire comme ça mais
étant interrogé sur ce point j'ai
souhaité aider la commission pour donner
un avis de recevabilité alors que
le propos du ministratal n'engageait pas
formellement le gouvernement et
d'ailleurs on le voit puisque le
gouvernement prend une position
défavorable donc ne couvre pas la
mandement donc je remercie vous pouvez
remercier le ministre total deuxième
point
vous pouvez remercier à ce stade le
ministre au bon parce que il pourrait à
tout moment se lever et dire article 40
on retire il ne le fait pas donc
profitons de ce moment de grâce pour
essayer de voter cette amendement
merci monsieur le Président je donne la
parole maintenant à notre collègue
monsieur gay
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues donc c'est
un amendement qui va dans le bon sens
faut le dire par contre que je
qualifierais pas de avancer social ou de
conquête sociale pour des millions de
travailleurs on est loin quand même de
la philosophie d'Ambroise Croizat parce
que je vais revenir sur les chiffres
les départs anticipés pour les accidents
du travail ou les maladies
professionnelles qui entraînent une
incapacité permanente aujourd'hui dans
le texte et vous l'avez reconnu monsieur
le ministre combien de personnes 3000
3000 personnes chaque année et si on
élargit tous les critères donc je ne
suis pas sûr et c'est pour ça que je
pose la question à monsieur le
rapporteur ça pourrait concerner au
maximum 20 000 personnes voilà de quoi
nous parlons c'est très bien et nous
allons prendre et nous allons voter mais
lorsque on vient avant-hier de voter le
recul de l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans pour
des millions de travailleurs et
travailleuses et que on a un tout petit
pas pour au maximum 20 000 travailleurs
et travailleuses je mets un bémol sur
grande conquête sociale vous m'en
excuserez et puis après on a une
deuxième chose il faut en venir sur les
critères pénibilités qui vont permettre
encore d'élargir il y en a quatre qui
ont été enlevés est-ce qu'on peut se
mettre d'accord d'avoir le débat entre
nous exposition aux agents chimiques
dangereux enlever depuis 2017 est-ce
qu'on le rajoute
manutention manuelle de charge est-ce
qu'on continue à l'enlever ou on le
rajoute
posture pénible et vibrations mécanique
c'est les deux derniers est-ce que on
maintient qu'on continue à exclure où on
le rajoute parce que ça ça permet
d'élargir l'assiette vous voyez
peut-être potentiellement de monter à
40000 personnes donc évidemment pour
cela on va le voter mais enfin on est
très loin je vous le dis monsieur le
rapporteur d'une grande conquête sociale
ce matin merci chers collègues madame
poumerol
après oui merci madame la Présidente
effectivement depuis des jours nous
assistons sur la perte de quatre
critères de pénibilité qui a été décidée
par Monsieur Macron en 2017 et c'est
vrai que je dirais que c'était
l'abonnement va certes dans le bon sens
mais moi je le taxerai pas d'avancer
social mais plutôt de non recul par
rapport à ce qui était prévu dans le
texte je pense que effectivement il faut
s'entendre sur les critères et comment
ils vont être
inclus de nouveau pour pouvoir élargir
l'assiette parce que comme il vient de
le dire mon collègue Fabien gay cette
mesure ne va toucher que très peu
d'agents et que donc il faut être
vigilant et pouvoir essayer d'élargir au
maximum l'assiette il va toutefois
monsieur salarié dans le bon sens et
nous sommes et nous le voterons donc
avec plaisir
pour précision madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues juste une
petite précision budgétaire et je vous
prie de de m'excuser monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
en fait juste une précision c'était les
mots là ne portait pas à utiliser
l'article 40 pourquoi parce que nous
sommes dans finalement dans ce qui
existe dans le périmètre d'aujourd'hui
donc en réalité vous n'aviez pas opposé
les recevabilités par l'article 40 c'est
plutôt pour un sujet qui qui va suivre
c'est la retraite progressive donc je
voulais le préciser en réalité cette
proposition nous l'avons faite parce que
justement nous pensons que pour un
certain nombre de public les choses sont
difficiles le travail est difficile et
que leur demander cet effort n'était pas
concevable donc je remercie l'ensemble
des collègues qui se sont exprimés pour
dire qu'effectivement eux aussi ils
considéraient que c'était finalement une
mesure de solidarité dans ce projet qui
est difficile on le sait bien passer à
de 62 à 64 ans voilà tout le monde le
dit
ça fait pas l'unanimité c'est clair mais
justement pour ce public en difficulté
nous avons souhaité maintenir et nous
vous invitons à voter cet amendement
alors avant de vous donner la parole
monsieur le ministre
je vous informe que 11 sous amendements
viennent d'être déposés sur l'amendement
numéro 21 38 alors que les explications
de vote avaient déjà commencé monsieur
le ministre je vous donne la parole
merci madame la Présidente simplement de
mots d'abord pour dire au Président
carotique si ma fonction me permettait
de donner des haies favorables à tous
les amendements déposés y compris quand
je peux considérer qu'ils ont un intérêt
sur le fond alors qu'il controviennent à
une recherche d'équilibre budgétaire et
quand bien même ça se passe en dehors
des systèmes du Borne des systèmes de
retraite ma vie serait certainement plus
agréable qu'elle ne l'est parfois quand
je suis au bon ceci étant dit je sais
bien que cette amendement présente un
certain nombre d'intérêts et que nous
pouvons en discuter de manière
extrêmement sereine quand on est sur cet
amendement 21 38 de Monsieur Savary
malgré tout je tiens à répéter deux
choses d'abord une première chose que je
ne répète pas mais que je dis en réponse
au président rénal pour dire que le
gouvernement a lui-même était
circonspect en matière d'articles 40 et
d'appuyer sur la déclaration que vous
avez mentionné la deuxième chose pour
dire que
le rapporteur tout à l'heure a dit a
raison que la durée d'exposition tout
comme la question la question relative à
la commission pluridisciplinaire relevée
du champ réglementaire mais le sujet est
très sérieux donc je vais éviter
l'expression fromage ou dessert fromage
et dessert mais ça y ressemble un petit
peu et si par voie réglementaire le
gouvernement m'était en œuvre les
assouplissements auxquels nous avons
pensé en plus de cette adoption le coup
n'en serait que renchérit et ça fait
partie des choses qui ne sont pas
forcément agréables ceci étant
gouvernement et à la fois respectueux et
soucieux que soient respectés le vote de
la commission des affaires sociales et
l'expression d'un avis défavorable
n'empêche évidemment pas le Sénat de se
prononcer sur cet amendement et de faire
valoir sa position nous verrons ensuite
dans le cas de la commission mixte
paritaire si les choses prospèrent aussi
elles ne prospère pas le gouvernement
souhaite donc le Sénat puisse se
prononcer sur un certain nombre de
dispositions et j'apprends madame la
Présidente par votre intervention que
des sous amendements ont été déposés sur
cet amendement 21-38 je n'ai pas à dire
si le gouvernement regrette ou pas qu'il
y a des potes sous amendements ça serait
porté une appréciation sur leur contenu
ce n'est pas mon rôle par contre le
gouvernement souhaitant que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur des sujets de
fonds et celui-ci en étant en
application de l'article 44 à l'unan
neutre de la Constitution nous
considérons et le gouvernement considère
que totalement ou sous amendement déposé
sur cette amendement 21 38 et il n'ayant
pas été examiné par la pas été examinée
par la commission sans y recevable
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc
conformément à l'article 4 alinéa 2 de
la Constitution à l'article 46 bis
alinéa du règlement le gouvernement
s'oppose à l'examen des sous amendements
à l'amendement numéro 21 38 qui n'ont
pas été antérieurement soumis à la
commission madame la Présidente de
commission confirmez-vous que c'est sous
amendement n'ont pas été soumis
antérieurement à la commission avant
l'ouverture du débat je le confirme
madame la Présidente merci dans ces
conditions c'est sous amendement ne
peuvent être examinés
je mets donc alors nous avons un rappel
plusieurs rappels aux règlements madame
Rossignol madame Rossignol rappelle aux
règlements
je vous en prie
nous allons écouter les rappels aux
règlements
non mais madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre ça vous a pas suffi hier
soir vous avez aimé ça ou quoi c'est
votre vous avez une petite une petite
addiction votre rappel au règlement s'il
vous plaît allez-y madame la Présidente
si des fils pendant que vous parlez à ma
place je prendrai la suite monsieur le
ministre une addiction on rappeller au
règlement 12 amendements là vous
déclenchez
ce vote les recevabilité ça maintenant
pour 12 amendements mais autant parfois
je peux tout en contestant et le
combattant imaginez en me mettant votre
place pourquoi vous le faites quand il y
en a un grand nombre mais pour 12 si
c'est pas nous priver du débat sur les
sujets sérieux comment et puis comment
ça va finir cette affaire là si à 12
vous vous énervez dites-le franchement
vous voulez pas débattre avec nous
comment elle s'appelle
madame Cohen pour rappel au règlement
oui merci madame la Présidente au nom du
44 bis écoutez hier il y a eu des
rappels au règlement du fait des
procédures que vous avez déclenchées
aujourd'hui pour 12 amendements 12
amendements qui étaient extrêmement
important parce que enfin dans cette
émission on allait parler des métiers et
de la vie des gens et de la pénibilité
et puis moi je m'étonne d'une chose
c'est que madame la Présidente de la
Commission se lève en disant que la
commission par exemple appelle en
priorité telle ou tel amendement on sait
pas réunis après on nous dit que comme
ça pas les sous amendements n'ont pas
été examinés par la commission ils sont
rejetés mais réunissez-nous et on va on
va on va on va décider à ensemble
collectivement avec une majorité enfin
c'est extraordinaire de parler au nom de
la commission quand elle ne se réunit
pas la commission c'est la Présidente
c'est le rapporteur c'est qui la
commission
pour rappel au règlement monsieur gay
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur Miss
mes chers collègues je voulais pas le
faire mais je vais le faire
non mais attendez attendez
pas de provocation on est dans le
règlement
ce matin on a demandé une demande de
priorité et je voulais m'exprimer mais
comme c'est un amendement important je
pensais qu'il fallait le débat comme
nous toutes et tous ici mais à un moment
donné le règlement il est pas fait pour
régler une question politique je voulais
déjà dit mais pour organiser notre vie
commune donc quand on est aux banques
ici en bas là moi je l'ai jamais été
mais quand on est au bord
on est rapporteur on est rapporteur de
la commission on entend bien rapporteur
de la commission pas d'un groupe
politique même majoritaire de la
commission donc je lis bien article 44-7
ou tirer 6 pardonnez-moi les demandes de
priorité ou de réserve dont l'effet en
cas d'adoption ou de modifier lors de
discussion des articles d'un texte ou
des amendements comme ça a été fait ce
matin
lorsqu'elle est demandée par la
Commission saisie au fond par la
commission ni par la présidente ni par
le rapporteur par la commission donc moi
je demande une question je vous pose
quand c'est que la Commission a été
s'est réuni pour délibérer sur la
demande de priorité c'est une question
là là c'est l'utilisation du règlement
n'ont pas régler une question politique
mais pour l'organisation de nos débats
parce que si nous crions comme nous le
faisons depuis deux jours beaucoup
beaucoup de nouveautés alors là je vous
le dis ça laissera des traces dans les
prochaines débats dans les prochaines
semaines et prochains mois voilà non
mais tranquillement et de façon apaisée
donc quand c'est que la Commission a
pris la commission après dans la
commission quand vous êtes majoritaire
il y a un vote et donc pas de problème
la demande de priorité sera acceptée par
l'ensemble de notre assemblée je vous
remercie
monsieur le rapporteur
les choses avaient bien commencé
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
on redescend sur terre on se met à la
portée effectivement de nos concitoyens
qui nous demandent des réponses d'accord
très bien ça fait combien de jours que
j'ai passé cet amendement à la
commission combien de jours ça fait
28 février depuis le 28 février est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas que quelque part
quand on mène une réflexion approfondie
on a quand même le temps par rapport aux
propositions faites par la Commission de
se retourner de faire en sorte de faire
même des auditions j'ai refait moi des
auditions par ma part je suis sûr que
vous en avez faite donc vous pouviez
effectivement m'alerter pour que on
puisse prenne pour que l'on puisse
prendre les décisions nécessaires c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'estime mais
peut-être ai-je Tor que les
sous-amendements qui sont déposés dans
la précipitation sans qu'il y ait
d'études d'impact ne se relève pas de la
commission me semble-t-il il relève
d'une réflexion que nous aurions pu
ensemble enrichir à travers des réunions
de commission tranquille dans la
sérénité nous mettons éventuellement des
auditions supplémentaires qui auraient
fait que le Sénat aurait pu faire son
travail et rentrer de façon plus
magnifique dans le texte voilà ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens c'est la
raison pour laquelle il me semble qu'un
amendement comme celui-là qui est
largement partagé largement partagé vous
l'avez dit sur tous les bancs méritent
pas franchement d'être à travers ce
texte modifié quelque part vous vous en
seriez rendu compte s'il avait fallu le
modifier avant en conséquence quand tout
le monde sait exprimé il me semble tout
à fait naturel que nous passions au vote
merci
pour Monsieur canard pour rappel au
règlement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord un petit mot par
rapport à un rappel au règlement qui a
été porté par Monsieur Olivier nous hier
tardivement dans un état d'utilisation
assez particulier mais je tiens à lui
dire que mon mal-être il est tout à fait
bien surmonté monsieur et nous et que
nos groupes de gauche sont parfaitement
unis c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
chez vous il m'a bien semblé au groupe
Ussé je ferme la parenthèse
c'était sur l'article 406 bis madame la
Présidente
mais dans le règlement il y a aussi les
attaques personnelles qui sont évoquées
sur le 46 bis moi j'ai une question à
poser à la droite sénatoriale et à la
droite à l'hygiène
c'est une question c'est combien combien
de sous amendements vous nous permettez
en générosité partagée de déposer sur ce
texte
si vous me dites trois bah on déposera 3
5 8
mais c'est un droit nous avons le droit
mes chers collègues de déposer des sous
amendements ça peut être dérangeant pour
vous mais c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
premièrement premièrement deuxièmement
deuxièmement effectivement monsieur
ministre c'est la deuxième fois que
d'utiliser le 44.2 pour bloquer nos
débats mais c'est une forme de j'ai
envie de dire de d'armes nucléaire
tactique
vous avez une autre arme nucléaire
stratégique c'est utiliser le 44 dans
toute sa globalité et d'utiliser donc le
vote bloqué sur la base des amendements
que vous aurez accepté mais si c'est
cela vous voulez pour arrêter le débat
dites le nous le plus vite possible
comme cela les Français seront pris à
témoin de la manière dont vous gérez le
Parlement monsieur Gontard pour rappel
au règlement
merci merci Madame l'ami mais madame
présidente monsieur le ministre
certes il y a le droit mais il y a aussi
l'abus de droit quand on s'écarne de
l'esprit de la Constitution la décision
du gouvernement me paraît d'ailleurs
largement improvisée elle augure mal des
discussions à venir sur le débat
parlementaire monsieur le ministre je
vous demande solennellement de prendre
les mesures nécessaires dans la journée
pour que le débat ait lieu il n'est pas
bon de soumettre ainsi le Parlement à un
rapport de force inadmissible recourir à
des instruments de rationalisation du
parlementarisme quand l'on dispose d'une
telle majorité constitue à mes yeux un
aveu de faiblesse de la part du
gouvernement nul besoin de recourir à de
tels artifices si l'on dispose
d'arguments convaincants
pardonnez la VMA c'est la solidarité de
mon propos mais un autre ton ne pouvait
convenir quand le moment est si grave
ce sont les paroles de Philippe Bas
questeur en 2018 sur le texte d'André
Chassaigne pour les retraites agricoles
parce que effectivement le gouvernement
utilisé ce type d'artifice donc je pense
que aujourd'hui on pourrait revenir un
petit peu au sérieux monsieur le
ministre ce n'est pas sérieux d'utiliser
et de supprimer une douzaine de sous
amendements sur un amendement
d'importance comme l'a dit monsieur
karucci a priori plutôt bien construit
et donc quand je continuerons continuons
justement à le construire pour notre
part notre groupe on avait un sous
amendement on est quand même très très
loin de l'obstruction on était pour
ajouter pour discuter pour améliorer
améliorer cette amendement donc je pense
que là franchement on avait
effectivement bien débuté dans les
quelques minutes de notre de notre débat
ce matin je pensais que la nuit avait
été bonne pour chacun je pense qu'il
faut redescendre ben voilà je pense
qu'il faut peut-être revenir de la
sérénité on a il nous reste à peu près
un peu moins de 1000 amendements
travaillons sur ces oui travaillons sur
ces amendements travaillant sur ses
amendements avançons et tout ira bien
merci alors j'ai encore deux rappels au
règlement monsieur le ministre vous
souhaitez prendre la parole avant
merci madame la Présidente quelques mots
d'abord nous nous connaissons depuis
longtemps avec madame la Présidente
rossignols et même si nous avons un
désaccord sur ce texte et peut-être sur
d'autres je pense que madame la
Présidente me demandait
ce qui m'a donné du plaisir hier soir ou
pas
et d'addiction je pense madame la
Présidente que si j'avais utilisé le
même vocabulaire pour vous interpeller
vous m'en auriez fait rire
donc vraiment vraiment madame la
Présidente je pense que vous me l'auriez
reproché et peut-être que d'ailleurs
vous auriez eu raison de le faire mais
je ne le fais pas à votre à votre
endroit je le sens simplement je pense
qu'on peut éviter ce genre de
vocabulaire la deuxième chose pour
répondre au président Kanner je suis le
président vous avez le droit de déposer
des sous amendements de la même manière
ton application de cet article 44-2 le
gouvernement a le droit de s'opposer à
l'examen de l'ensemble des
sous-amendements déposés sur un
amendement ou un article dès lors qu'ils
n'ont pas été examinés par la commission
préalablement
deuxième troisième point pardonnez-moi
troisième point sur l'intérêt
l'opportunité la pertinence de d'évoquer
d'avoir recours aux 44 de en l'état il y
a deux choses qui m'ont amené à le faire
la première c'est que j'ai en tête un
passage du débat d'hier un débat initié
par le président le comptoir sur une
liste monsieur le Président de 140
amendements 45-40 sous amendements que
vous aviez déposé demandant que soit
consulter
telle caisse de retraite telle organisme
de conseil 140 amendements
qui avaient été déposé et que vous avez
défendu de manière assez rapide je dois
dire avec une dizaine d'intervenants et
que vous avez tous retiré et donc je me
suis dit j'ai pensé que si nous entrions
dans un débat qui consistait à déposer
des sous-amendements pour les défendre
prendre du temps pour les défendre
retarder le vote et ensuite les retirer
on perdait peut-être en opportunité puis
la deuxième raison c'est que j'ai
regardé rapidement les sous amendements
qui ont été déposés pendant que les
explications de vote avaient commencé la
première remarque que je me suis faite
c'est une remarque identique à celle de
Monsieur le Rapporteur cet amendement
est adopté par la commission le 28
février et je considère que si les sous
amendements qui sont déposés sont aussi
essentielles au débat peut-être qu'ils
auraient pu être déposés avant le début
des explications de vote sauf à vouloir
au dernier moment retarder ce même vote
et j'ai regardé par ailleurs les sous
amants qui ont été déposés
beaucoup d'entre vous ont une grande
expérience parlementaire et nous savons
tous que lorsqu'on commence à écrire
notamment dans un amendement ou un sous
amendement en général on perd en
lisibilité ou en évidence et la plupart
des amendements en tout cas pour ceux
que j'ai vu commence par notamment et
vise à ajouter à l'amendement du
rapporteur des professions pour dire en
cas d'incapacité permanente notamment
pour par exemple nous avons le
sous-amendement
numéro et que je ne dise pas de bêtises
972 qui dit notamment pour les moniteurs
d'école de conduite il y a certainement
un travail et une discussion à voir sur
leurs conditions de travail mais je
pense que nous pouvons ainsi décliner
les sous-amendements autant qu'il y a de
profession deuxième exemple
un amendement insoum amendement numéro
967 qui dit notamment pour les
professeurs des écoles et là celui-ci
m'a encore plus interpellé et en tout
cas à mes yeux il relève d'une volonté
d'obstruction la retraite pour
incapacité permanente ne concerne pas
les agents publics
et on a la des sous amendements qui
viennent sur des professions publiques
qui partent nocturnes sont pas concernés
par le dispositif proposé par le
rapporteur quel est l'autre intérêt que
de retarder le moment du vote et le
retarder pour le Sénat la capacité de se
prononcer sur le fond à propos d'un
capacité permanente
[Applaudissements]
pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mais mes chers collègues la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
fait qu'il intervient très très peu sur
l'organisation de notre débats très
rarement monsieur le ministre quand le
gouvernement utilise
l'article 41 et l'article 44 2 de la
Constitution vous vous introduisez
directement dans le débat de notre
assemblée et vous donnez par la même la
possibilité aux conseils constitutionnel
de donner un avis sur nos débats en
faisant ça non seulement vous fragilisez
l'article 9 parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel va regarder précisément
dans le détail les modalités de son
adoption et donc va regarder nos débats
mais par ailleurs chers collègues vous
fragilisez aussi la capacité du Sénat à
organiser librement ses débats merci
madame la Présidente
monsieur rénal pour rappel au règlement
non très très court et sur le même
fondement simplement pour dire que le
rapporteur nous a fait une réponse qui
n'était pas la bonne à m'excusant il a
été questionné sur le fonctionnement de
la commission dont il est le rapporteur
donc moi j'attends toujours qu'il nous
réponde sur le fond sur la question moi
je le dis parce que ce qui me gêne cette
affaire qui est le fait que la
Commission soit pas réuni et
préalablement alors que c'est alors que
c'est tout bêtement le règlement c'est
que mes chers collègues c'est votre
c'est vous qui avez ouvert ces questions
réglementaires avec l'article 38 je vous
le rappelle c'est vous qui avez ouvert
le sujet d'un strict respect strict
respect des règles de fonctionnement et
bien si un strict respect que ce respect
est lieu et que les choses se fassent à
l'avenir correctement et donc on a vu
aujourd'hui une façon de faire c'est
fait
voilà et à l'avenir faisons les choses
déjà correctement dans l'ordre c'est
tout réglementaire pas plus
après
merci Madame à la présidente rappelle au
règlement article 44 2
mes chers collègues depuis
presque 10 jours le mot principal c'est
débats vous voulez le débat et vous
regrettez que le débat n'est pas lieu
mais vous voulez une forme particulière
de débat vous voulez le débat sans fin
c'est une stratégie c'est la stratégie
de la paralysie vous avez transformé ces
travées en tranchées c'est votre choix
néanmoins quelle est la mission d'un
parlement ce n'est pas seulement de
parlementer c'est aussi de légiférer
légiférer c'est-à-dire délibéré voter
décider ce n'est pas votre but
malheureusement
et en choisissant la stratégie de la
paralysie inconsciemment ou
involontairement vous nourrissez vous
renforcer le vent mauvais de
l'antiparlementarisme
vous renforcez
les sirènes du populisme mes chers amis
attention au boomerang
monsieur carucci
[Applaudissements]
le ministre on avait bien démarré
on se met à peu près d'accord sur un
amendement et au moment des explications
de vote 19 sous amendements
sincèrement si ça c'est pas de
l'obstruction je sais pas comment ça
s'appelle si vous aviez tant d'idées
pour sous-amander cette amendement qui a
été adopté par la commission le 28
février c'était il y a 12 jours pendant
12 jours silence radio et puis d'un coup
une masse d'amendement de sous
amendement qui tombe ce qui veut dire
très clairement que votre intention
c'est de ne pas aller au bout du débat
votre intention c'est à chaque
amendement de déposer des sous
amendements c'est de l'obstruction
presque caricaturale à partir de là
la décision du gouvernement d'appliquer
le 44 2 est tout à fait normal et
légitime vous l'avez je vous rassure
quand vous étiez au gouvernement
largement utilisé
beaucoup utilisé dois-je vous rappeler
que par exemple la réforme Touraine a
été adoptée en deuxième lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale par un vote bloqué
un vote bloqué un vote bloqué par un
détail un vote bloqué donc je pense qu'à
la matière il faut rester assez serein
dire que si on veut aller au bout du
texte il faut que chacun y mette du sien
pardon monsieur le Président de canner
j'étais je le reconnais un peu choqué de
votre part parce que je vous estime
beaucoup mais
c'est être en photo entraînement j'ai le
règlement du Sénat pardon de vous dire
ce n'est pas digne de notre assemblée
madame Lubin pour rappel au règlement
non pas Madame le baron pardon
madame brûlin pardon excusez-moi madame
brûlin pour rappel au règlement monsieur
gay je ne vous donnerai pas la parole
une deuxième fois pour rappel au
règlement il y a madame appartient à la
parole
non non monsieur karoutine a fait une
explication de votre tout à l'heure
c'était pas une deuxième rappel au
règlement madame brun pour rappel au
règlement
merci madame la Présidente nous
assistons à une utilisation me
semble-t-il abusive
de la priorité appelée sur certains
amendements qui ne tient plus à assurer
la clarté de nos débats mais qui devient
une arme de destruction massive de
susamment lesquels sous amendement
viennent sous cette forme parce que un
certain nombre de nos amendements on ne
va pas y revenir mais c'est important de
le rappeler ont été déclarés
irrecevables pour des raisons qui
restent tout à fait obscures voilà
pourquoi on en est là aujourd'hui
il n'y a même plus
d'arguments réglementaire
sur l'annulation de ces sous amendements
il n'est plus question que de chiffres
tantôt 140 que ça peut faire tomber et
maintenant on en est arrivé à 12 faire
tomber 12 vous ne ferez croire à
personne que vous allez accélérer le
débat en faisant ça parce qu'à chaque
fois que vous utilisez ces procédures
nous le retardons
régulièrement vous le retarder
non
c'est un nom
c'est un nom collectif c'est un nom
c'est un nom c'est un nous collectif
collectivement collectivement par vos
procédures se débat est retardé enfin il
n'a pas été répondu à la question qui a
posé Fabien gay quand la commission
s'est-elle réunie pour demander cette
priorité va-t-elle le faire et va-t-elle
faire son travail puisque parce que nous
ne pouvons pas admettre que des sous
amendements soient rejetés au motif
qu'ils étaient dans la même veine que
des précédents ou qu'ils n'ont pas été
posés pendant les 12 derniers jours mais
vous savez qu'il s'est passé des choses
c'est 12 derniers jours vous savez ce
qui se passe dans le pays depuis cette
douze derniers jours et bien notre débat
doit s'il doit chers collègues
de ce qui se passe dans notre pays donc
oui il y a des choses
pour un rappel au règlement
oui merci même ma présidente alors je
veux rappeler effectivement que nous
défendons cet amendement seulement moi
j'ai pas encore perçu pourquoi il a été
mis prioritaire il pouvait très bien
être défendu dans sa place donc la
commission effectivement nous a jamais
informé que quel que soit quelque soit
le moment où on reprendra la discussion
à la commission elle aurait pu dire
celui-là on le mettra prioritaire on
vous informe ce qui aurait quand même
permis que ça soit une décision de la
Commission plutôt qu'une décision
simplement du rapporteur
moi monsieur le ministre je suis quand
même étonné vous empêchez donc ces 12
amendements d'être défendus mais vous
les commentez ça c'est quand même
incroyable en malhonnêteté
intellectuelle c'est à dire on a deux
amendements vous dites ils ne seront pas
discutés et vous prenez la parole pour
dire en quoi ils sont ridicules en quoi
ils vous semblent en quoi il vous semble
44 10 on se calme donc je veux dire il y
a vraiment souvent parce que moi je peux
je comprends pas l'intention de la
priorité de cet amendement et puis là
aussi vous continuez vous parlez de nos
intentions c'est bien vous lisez mais la
tension en droit je veux dire c'est très
difficile
même pour la faute grave il faut prouver
l'attention de nuire et je sais que pour
la faute lourde pardon et que les
employeurs ils renoncent parce que
l'intention elle a prouvé c'est quand
même très très difficile alors
effectivement vous avez pas voulu
prendre le temps de ces 12 amendements
c'est cela que disait ma collègue
communiste regardez nous les aurions
défendus le temps qu'on proteste qu'on
trouve aux méthodes prendra plus de
temps que la défense de nos 12
amendements
oui madame la Présidente mon rappel au
règlement s'appuie sur
l'article 13 du chapitre 6 de notre
règlement et les articles suivants
relatifs à l'organisation des travaux
des commissions je suis quand même
extrêmement surpris mais chers collègues
que il n'est pas été répandu ni même
tenté de répondre
dans une approche éloignée à la question
de savoir en quoi la commission des
affaires sociales
pouvaient se préoccuper de la
recevabilité de certains amendements
est-ce une décision solitaire de notre
collègue présidente de commission ou du
rapporteur ou est-ce une décision
collégiale vous voyez j'ai eu le
l'honneur pendant trois ans avant mon
collègue rénal de présider la commission
des finances qui est avec la commission
des affaires sociales celle qui a
examiné qui a à examiner des textes
financiers et qui par ailleurs par
tradition depuis maintenant un certain
nombre d'années et confiait un élu d'un
groupe d'opposition et quand on est dans
cette position politique ça oblige à une
certaine modestie c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut quand même très
prudemment observé ce qui relève de
l'espace de décision personnelle du
président par exemple la censure au
titre de l'article 40 des nominations
individuelles que sais-je et ce qui
relève du travail collectif de la
Commission et encore faut-il pour que ce
travail collectif puisse se dérouler
qu'elle se rémunisse donc je repose la
question de savoir quand notre
commission des affaires sociales a eu à
examiner la recevabilité d'un certain
nombre d'amendement
lors des
examens de loi de finances nous
réunissons la commission des finances le
matin avant la séance parfois assez tôt
de façon à pouvoir balayer tout un tas
d'examens qui ont été déposés dans la
nuit je ne vois pas en quoi la
commission des affaires sociales ne
pourrait pas faire un travail de même
nature
madame m'a pour ce poli pour explication
pour rappel au règlement pardon merci en
vertu donc de l'article 44 bis nous
évoquons ici 12 amendements 12
amendements monsieur le ministre que
vous avez caricaturé parce que vous avez
oublié de dire que dans ces dans ces
sous amendements nous évoquons les
sages-femmes les infirmiers psy les
puéricultrices bon voilà hein alors oui
la commission s'est réunie monsieur
Savary et vous l'avez dit
une la fois passée au mois de février
pour dire que votre amendement était
recevable on n'a pas de souci sur ça
mais pourquoi est-il mis en priorité
avec ma collègue Laurence Cohen et
d'autres d'ailleurs nous participons aux
commissions des affaires sociales nous
sommes présents à la commission des
affaires sociales on peut pas dire le
contraire mes collègues vous ne pouvez
pas dire ici sur les bancs qu'avec
Laurence Cohen et mes collègues de
gauche et vous d'ailleurs nous ne soyons
pas attentif à cette commission des
affaires sociales nous y sommes à toute
pratiquement
à toutes non mais ça serait de mauvaise
foi que vous nous disiez ça parce que
nous sommes présentes en commission des
affaires sociales et nous y participons
merci merci de redire madame douano
qu'effectivement nous sommes présents
que vous l'avez pas dit merci madame
douanot de reconnaître que nous sommes
présentes à ces commissions des affaires
sociales alors alors
je reviens pourquoi est-ce que le
rapporteur avec la présidente décide de
nous faire passer pour des pantins et de
ne pas réunir à nouveau cette commission
des affaires sociales et pourquoi est-ce
que vous décidez à deux trois ici sur
les bancs de la majorité sénatorial de
ne pas nous réunir
monsieur kerouge pour rappel au
règlement
dans la présidente monsieur le ministre
bis Repetti ta place Sainte nous avions
prévenu et vous recommencez la même
perspective que celle que vous avez
lancée hier soir c'est très très bien
c'est sur la base du 46 2 du règlement
pour que tout le monde soit soit à
l'aise alors plusieurs points puisque
certains nous donnent des cours sur ce
que devrait être le Parlement j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour répondre sans
acrimonie aucune à notre collègue
Hainaut qui nous a interpellé hier
Patrick canard et moi-même pour lui dire
d'une part que c'est très certes
confortable mais on ne choisit pas son
opposition et que effectivement nous
sommes à gauche déterminés contre cette
réforme et ensuite j'ai entendu
également monsieur Pacaud nous faire un
cours sur ce que devrait être le
Parlement alors et je le dis avec
modestie d'ailleurs j'invite à Monsieur
Hainaut à les parcourir s'il le souhaite
j'ai une petite expérience sur la
matière et petite bibliographie qu'il
peut éventuellement consulter sur ce
sujet précisément le Parlement le
Parlement n'est pas
une espèce d'enceinte administrative
dans laquelle il faut prendre
automatiquement des décisions un
parlement c'est aussi la traduction des
rapports de force dans une société c'est
aussi simple que ça et on l'espèce vous
tentez de brider ses rapports de force
alors ne vous étonnez pas ne vous
étonnez pas de la situation que vous
avez vous-même créé je l'ai dit hier je
le répète donc vous livrerai à ce petit
jeu nous ferons exactement le même le
débat n'avance pas c'est un choix
manifestement que vous souhaitez
conforter il est ridicule nous ne
pouvons pas avancer continuons
écoutez monsieur Pacaud vos jugements
n'engagent que vous mais les Français
les Français voient le ridicule de la
situation et on vous remercie
le président Laurent pour un rappel aux
règlements
merci madame la Présidente
c'est abus des procédures réglementaires
juste pour rigoler un peu il paraît que
l'imprimerie ici est en rupture de stock
parce que tout le monde apprend par cœur
le Règlement du Sénat voilà où on en est
arrivé mais je voudrais faire un
commentaire sur ce qu'a dit ma collègue
ponce à propos de l'intervention du
ministre parce que non seulement la
Commission ne prend visiblement pas la
peine de réunir la commission des
affaires sociales pour examiner le
problème de la recevabilité des
amendements mais semble-t-il si j'en
crois les commentaires du ministre la
liste des amendements qui sont
déclarésor recevables et faites sous la
dictée du ministre et ça c'est
extrêmement grave
parce que et pour cette raison je veux
le redire au poids où nous en sommes et
vu l'usage répété de cette
irrecevabilité la réunion de la
commission des affaires sociales après
une suspension de séance devient
absolument indispensable sinon ça veut
dire que cette liste d'amendements
irrecevable serait dans les couloirs
entre le ministre et la présidence de la
Commission et les rapporteurs c'est à la
Commission d'examiner cette question et
pas au ministre de venir nous commenter
des amendements qui ne seront même pas
soumis au débat
merci président
enfin pour un deuxième rappel aux
règlements monsieur gay mais j'espère
que ça ne fera pas jurisprudence il a il
en a le droit et ensuite je mets au vote
règlement quel article
ce que vient de dire le président
Laurent attendez on vous propose
ensemble
une sortie de crise non mais
je relis
je relis parce que vous nous répondez
pas ni le rapporteur ni le ministre
lorsqu'il est demandé par la Commission
saisie au fond sur la question de
modifier l'ordre de discussion d'un
article ou des amendements je le dis
parce qu'il y a madame la Présidente
prima et donc si je mens elle le dira
lorsque ça nous est arrivé depuis 5 ans
d'avoir des demandes de priorité soit on
l'a évoqué en commission
soit c'est vrai et président en caoutchi
l'a dit elle a eu et non normal elle a
prévenu l'ensemble des chefs de fil par
groupe politique pour dire je demanderai
sur tel ou tel amendement de le placer
en priorité vrai ou pas madame la
Présidente vous le savez on ne l'a
jamais découvert en séance publique ce
que vous êtes en train de faire depuis
hier on demandant des priorités sans
réunir la commission n'est pas
acceptable et ce qu'a dit le président
Laurent est extrêmement important c'est
la séparation entre l'exécutif et le
Parlement ce n'est pas au ministre de
décider si tel ou tel amendement ou
sous-amendement est valable ou pas c'est
à la commission qui fait le tri si la
commission se réunit en 5 minutes et
décide ensemble que les sous-amendements
ne sont pas recevables alors nous
l'accepterons mais nous ne pouvons pas
tripatouiller le règlement comme cela
nous sommes en train de créer des
précédents extrêmement dangereux qu'ici
demain
c'est un pouvoir autoritaire ou
fascisant il aura toutes les armes parce
qu'il n'y ci il n'y a que des
républicains démocrates dans cette
mystique mais il aura tous les pouvoirs
pour annuler en réalité le pouvoir des
sénatrices et des sénateurs et de notre
assemblée faisons attention ne trie pas
toujours pas le règlement comme ça nous
arrange réunissant la Commission en 5
minutes et la faire
au règlement je me vois je mets donc au
voie cet amendement avec un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui vote
pour
je mets aux voix l'amendement qui vote
qui va contre
il est adopté monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci merci madame la Présidente je
souhaitais madame présente intervenir
mais juste un mot de réaction et le
sénateur game n'en prendra pas ombrage
j'en suis sûr sur le sénateur vous dites
que je déciderai de ce qui est recevable
ou il recevable en réalité pour être
tout à fait précis l'article 44 2 de la
Constitution n'autorise pas le
gouvernement à dire si tu en amendement
est recevable ou il recevable c'est la
prérogative de la commission par contre
l'article 44 2 autorise le gouvernement
à refuser l'examen de sous amendement et
d'amendements qui n'ont pas été examinés
préalablement par la commission ça n'est
pas une appréciation sur la recevabilité
c'est une procédure constitutionnelle
qui m'autorise aujourd'hui comme membre
du gouvernement a refusé que ce soit
soumis à l'examen des articles qui n'ont
pas fait l'objet d'une adoption
ceci étant ceci étant madame
ceci étant madame la Présidente ceci
étant madame la Présidente je sollicite
de votre bienveillance une suspension de
séance de 15 minutes
je suspends la séance donc pour
15 blagues tout à l'heure
mes chers collègues la séance est
reprise je donne la parole à Monsieur le
Ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
nous débattons du projet de loi de
financement la sécurité sociale
rectificative depuis le 2 mars dernier
dans cette émission vos travaux ont
commencé les jours précédents en
commission de très nombreuses
amendements ont été déposés examinés et
les débats ont été nourris
nous avons eu ensemble dans cette
émission 74 heures de débat sur un sujet
central celui de l'avenir d'un système
de retraite par répartition
à chaque article malgré des discussions
de fond malgré des avancées portées par
la commission bien sûr par plusieurs
groupes nous le regrettons mais
l'obstruction est devenue un choix
méthodique et répété des groupes
d'opposition nous avons eu quelques
illustrations pas plus tard que ce matin
je pense à la déclaration de madame la
sénatrice brûle qui nous dit très
clairement et je la remercie de cette
clarté qu'à chaque fois que nous avons
nous avancerons tous sera mis en oeuvre
pour nous ralentir je pense aux
expressions utilisées hier au sujet du
dépôt des sous amendements qui ont été
présentés comme une vie sans fin et avec
la volonté de faire en sorte que le
nombre de sous-amands déposés soit
toujours plus important pour empêcher le
sauna de se prononcer dans la clarté sur
l'ensemble du texte et sur les
dispositions de fonds je pense aux
séries d'amendements identiques ou
analogue avec des déclinaisons de
profession avec des déclinaisons
d'institutions à concerter avec des
déclinaisons de date lorsque les sous am
donc comme seul objet que de décaler
d'un jour puis de deux jours puis deux
trois jours puis de 4 jours la date de
remise d'un rapport lui-même demandé par
un parlementaire d'un groupe
d'opposition cela caractérise une
obstruction méthodique et une volonté de
priver le Sénat de sa capacité à
délibérer et à se prononcer dans la
clarté pour dire qui soutient et qui ne
soutient pas les dispositions qui sont
proposées le choix du gouvernement la
ligne du gouvernement la seule qui
vaille à nos yeux et celui de la clarté
des débats pour les sénateurs comme pour
les Français qui nous regardent et qui
vous regardent
nous faisons un choix clair nous avons
une volonté claire celui d'éviter de
contourner et de mettre fin à une
obstruction qui est devenue systématique
et qui n'a comme ça l'objectif je le
répète d'empêcher les sénateurs et les
sénatrices de se prononcer sur des
dispositions de ce texte et sur cette
réforme qui est majeure pour l'avenir
des Français
nous aurions pu considérer que le
calendrier parlementaire tel que prévu
par la Constitution la loi organique ce
réel suffisant nous considérons qu'il
est absolument essentiel que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur le fond dans la
clarté que cette clarté des positions
toute respectueuse dans l'opposition
comme dans la majorité dans le soutien
comme
l'opposition à ce texte mais que cette
clarté des débats est tout à fait
primordiale pour pouvoir ainsi avancer
et que cette réforme puisse continuer à
être discuté
c'est la raison pour laquelle mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
Présidente en application de l'article
44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du Règlement du
Sénat le gouvernement demande à votre
assemblée de se prononcer par un vote
unique sur l'ensemble du texte ainsi que
sur les articles 9 à 20 en retenant les
amendements et les sous amendements
suivants je vous ferai la liste dans un
instant mais en précisant que cette
annonce ne remet pas en cause ce qui a
déjà été examiné et adopté à l'article 9
avant la suspension de semences
le gouvernement propose que soit soumis
à se voit unique les amendements pardon
pour les itérations numéro 21 33 21 34
21 41 21 36 modifié par le
sous-amendement 471 21 35 21 37 21 39 21
43 21
44 21 46 21 47 21 48 21 50 et 21 52 à
l'article 9
pour ce qui concerne l'article l'article
10 les amendements 21 54 20 59 rectifié
terre 21 55 20 58 rectifié 20 60
rectifié bis 21 56 21 57 21 58 21 59 et
21 60 pour ce qui concerne les
amendements portant additionnels après
l'article 10 les amendements 22 95 20 24
20 21 61 rectifié bis 45 47
475 rectifié pour les amendements à
l'article 11
les amendements 24 88 rectifié bis et 21
62 pour les amendements portant arctique
additionnels après l'article 11 les
amants l'amendements numéro 19 04
rectifié bis et enfin l'article 12 les
amendements 2163 21 64 et 2165 ces
amendements adoptés pour par la
Commission pour la plupart sont des
amendements qui permettent d'améliorer
le texte qui vont nous permettre
d'améliorer et de créer de nouveaux
droits en matière de pension de
réversion pour les orphelins qui vont
nous permettre d'engager une
revalorisation des pensions à Mayotte
qui vont nous permettre de clarifier les
conditions d'accès à la location de
solidarité pour les personnes âgées qui
vont nous permettre d'intégrer les
indemnités journalières des congés
maternité avant 2012 dans les modalités
retenues pour le calcul des retraites
des femmes concernées
qui vont nous permettre d'apporter des
possibilités de validation trimestres
supplémentaires pour les
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires ou encore
qui vont nous permettre de donner suite
à un vote intervenu en première partie
permettant la modification du niveau
du niveau de l'objectif national de
dépenses en matière d'assurance maladie
autant d'amendements qui permettent
d'améliorer ce texte et qui permet de
poursuivre je tiens à préciser mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs que nous
allons pour ce qui concerne les articles
qui suivent notamment les tableaux
financiers avec mes excuses puisque
j'aurais dû traiter l'article 13 dans la
première série de numéros que j'ai
indiqué le gouvernement propose aussi
donc de retenir les articles les
amendements pardonnez-moi 21 66 21 67 21
69 21 70 21 72 21 73
214 21 75 21 76 21 77
ainsi que les amendements 23 60 rectifié
bis 21 78 21 79 21 80 21
82 à l'article 13 que nous proposons
aussi de retenir pour ce qui sera soumis
au vote unique les amendements 1369 et
21 83 qui portent arctique additionnelle
après l'article 13 l'amendement 25 25 63
pardon rectifier avant l'article 14
l'amendement 47 23 à l'article 14
l'amendement 47 24 à l'article 15 et
l'amendement 2184 à l'article 16
évidemment cette liste vaut exclusion de
tous les autres amendements y compris
des amendements portant article
additionnels
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc en
application de l'article 44 dernier
alinéa de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du règlement le
gouvernement demande au Sénat de se
prononcer par un seul vote sur les
articles 9 à 20 et sur l'ensemble du
texte en ne retenant à partir de
maintenant que les amendements proposés
ou acceptés par le gouvernement sans
remettre en cause les amendements
précédemment adoptés y compris ce
adopter jusque à cet article 9 les
amendements restants en discussion
retenus par le gouvernement viennent
d'être listés par le ministre il
reçoivent donc en quelque sorte un avis
favorable
si vous me l'autorisez je ne vous
redonnerai pas la liste vous allez avoir
la distribution de cette liste dans
quelques minutes
à l'exclusion donc de tous les autres y
compris des amendements portant articles
additionnels
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
nous avons bien entendu vos propos il
s'agit par le recours à cette procédure
d'assurer la clarté et la sincérité de
nos débats et de mettre un terme à
l'obstruction
mes chers collègues je vous rappelle que
dans le cadre de la procédure de vote
unique les auteurs des amendements
conservent leurs droits de présentation
en conséquence chaque amendement pourra
être soutenu pendant deux minutes et la
Commission et le gouvernement donneront
leur avis il n'y aura en revanche plus
d'explications de votes individuelle sur
chacun des amendements et des articles
je finis de vous expliquer et ensuite
vous ferez des rappels au règlement
laissez-moi finir vous expliquer et nous
ferons ensuite les rappels au règlement
mais certains souhaitent avoir cette
explication
de même les prises de parole sur
articles sont possibles dans les
conditions fixées par la décision de la
Conférence des Présidents réunis le 8
mars dernier c'est à dire à raison de
deux minutes pour un orateur par groupe
à l'issue de la présentation des
amendements nous passerons aux
explications de vote et au vote unique
sur les amendements retenus et sur
l'ensemble du texte
voilà les explications mes chers
collègues je vois quelques rappels aux
règlements monsieur canner pour rappel
au règlement
merci madame la Présidente sur la base
de l'article 44 bis
la messe est dite mes chers collègues
vous indiquez mes chers collègues que
voilà nous ne sommes pas étonnés
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure dans mon
rappel le règlement je me dis j'avais
dit à Monsieur mini mais quand
allez-vous sortir le 44 3
c'est fait c'est fait je vous rappelle
que si on en arrive là c'est parce que
bien évidemment des articles du
Règlement général du Sénat ont été
utilisés que le 47 1 de la Constitution
a été utilisée en amont par le
gouvernement et que la tactique et la
technique de la maman prioritaire
rectificatif a été utilisé pour faire
tomber nombre d'amendements de
l'opposition
nous vous donnons acte monsieur le
ministre et Mesdames et Messieurs etc de
sénatrice et sénateur de la droite
sénatoriale que vous avez décidé donc
avant la grande journée du 11 mars
de montrer au pays vos réels intentions
que je qualifierais et ne le voyait pas
mal de réactionnaires puisque c'est bien
une réforme réactionnaire dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui une réforme de
régression sociale il restait 1000
amendements à examiner il nous restait
plus de 30 heures de je crois de débats
et donc nous pourrions nous aurions pu
tranquillement montrer aux Français
notre volonté
nous allons nous allons nous allons
rester je vous assure nous serons en
séance pour débattre des amendements que
vous nous tolérez monsieur le ministre
en termes d'examen mais madame la
Présidente pour nous permettre néanmoins
de prendre acte mais aussi de considérer
les conséquences d'une telle décision du
gouvernement je sollicite de votre part
et je crois que ce sera bien légitime
une suspension de séance pour permettre
aux on a trois groupes de faire le point
de la situation
monsieur le Président je vais d'abord
prendre les autres rappels aux
règlements notamment celui de Monsieur
Gontard pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente sur l'article
44 bis
quel aveu de faiblesse quel aveu de
faiblesse ouais franchement
je crois que franchement je l'ai dit
beaucoup de fois ces derniers temps mais
là un terrible aveux de à votre
faiblesse oui votre majorité se fissure
ce texte n'a pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale et on a vu on a vu les
conditions
l'ensemble des syndicats Unis demandent
demande solennellement être reçue par le
Président de la République qui leur
refuse toujours d'ouvrir la porte et de
et de continuer des discussions
l'ensemble de la population est dans la
rue et attend une réponse et vous voulez
passer en force quelle image vous donnez
c'est d'une brutalité c'est une
aliénation du Parlement c'est tout
simplement honteux honteux
Victor Hugo avait appelé son chien Sénat
et oui le Sénat est devenu le toutou du
gouvernement voilà où on en est voilà où
on en est
alors
la majorité sénatoriale effectivement
voilà oui allez allez oui monsieur
carucci je sais que ça vous embête mais
je continuerai je continueai voilà oui
rappelle aux règlements oui on n'a pas
le droit de s'adresser quand je parle
voilà ok voilà
donc moi je demande également évidemment
une suspension de séance et une
suspension de séance qui soit suffisante
parce que vous vous accordez une
suspension de séance le gouvernement
s'accorde une suspension de séance pour
pouvoir réécrire son texte on a quand
même la possibilité de pouvoir réagir et
pouvoir se réunir mais en tout cas moi
je le dis on ne pourra pas continuer à
accepter cette allégation du du
Parlement et on nous on ne sera pas le
toutou du gouvernement
monsieur le Président Laurent pour
rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente nous y sommes voilà
donc le coup de force du gouvernement
que vous prépariez en fait depuis mardi
depuis les appels incessants au recours
à toutes les procédures pour mettre fin
au débat
comme l'a dit à plusieurs reprises la
présidente de notre groupe Eliane
assassy il s'agit effectivement d'un
terrible aveux de faiblesse vous qui
êtes ultra majoritaire au Sénat vous
êtes incapable de faire voter le texte
dans des conditions normales de débat
et tout cela parce que vous avez décidé
parce que vous avez décidé depuis le 1er
jour non seulement de faire voter les 64
ans mais de les faire voter en acceptant
les conditions imposées par le
gouvernement avec le recours aux 47 1 et
vous vous êtes mis dans une situation
d'abaissement du Sénat de jouer le jeu
que vous imposez le gouvernement vous
vous êtes condamné au silence pendant
les premiers jours du débat pour jouer
ce jeu puis à partir de mardi quand vous
avez vu que le mouvement populaire
prenait une telle ampleur vous avez
décidé l'obstruction c'est vous qui avez
organisé l'obstruction depuis mardi pour
finalement justifier ce coup de force du
gouvernement et vous allez donc aller
chers collègues à la CMP mercredi alors
que l'Assemblée nationale n'aura pas
voté le texte et qu'il aura été adopté
ici par au fait ce qu'il faut bien
appeler un 49 sénatorial parce que le
vote bloqué c'est la même chose donc
vous allez aller à la CNP je vous le dis
mes chers collègues de droite nos
cautionnez pas cela parce que vous le
paierez très cher dans le pays parce que
le pays vous regarde ne cautionnez pas
cela
la seule issue possible aujourd'hui
c'est le retrait du texte le retrait du
texte
madame Cohen pour Abel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente comme vient
de le dire mon collègue Pierre Laurent
le 44 3 c'est le 49.3 du Sénat et
franchement le Sénat ne sort pas grandi
par cette nouvelle procédure le
parlementarisme est piétiné par le
gouvernement je le dois le dire mais
avec la sentiment de la majorité de
droites LR
centriste et c'est triste c'est triste
pour la démocratie c'est triste pour le
peuple c'est triste pour tous celles et
tous ceux qui qui nous regardent et
franchement pourquoi vous avez fait ça
parce que depuis le début procédure sur
procédure vous avez souhaité tendre les
débats vous allez vous avez souhaité
dramatiser les débats et vous avez
refusé de parler du fond c'est à dire
des conséquences de votre projet sur la
vie des gens c'est ça la réalité et
pourquoi il y a une telle attitude des
droites avec le gouvernement c'est parce
que vaut le projet du gouvernement c'est
le frère jumeau de votre projet mesdames
et messieurs de droite puisque ça fait
quatre ans ça fait 4 ans que René Paul
Savary présente le recul de l'âge de la
retraite donc vous êtes enfin soulagé de
voir cette réforme scélérate votez de
cette manière là par des parlementaires
qui acceptent que le parlementarisme
soit piétiné c'est pas glorieux c'est
triste mais les conséquences vont être
graves parce que aujourd'hui vous
piétinez l'opposition et demain
qu'est-ce qui va se passer alors ne
mettez pas la main sur le cœur en disant
oh le Sénat c'est bien mieux que
qu'ailleurs nous nous sommes respectueux
c'est être respectueux que de bafouer
l'opposition de gauche de la baïonner
bah pour moi c'est antidémocratique et
c'est ce que vous faites et en plus la
commission des affaires sociales a été
piétiné puisque elle n'a jamais été
réunis depuis le début et ça c'est aussi
très grave
si Madame Rossignol madame la Présidente
Rossignol pour rappel aux règlements
merci madame la Présidente pour que tout
le monde à l'extérieur qui cherche à
comprendre qui s'instruit sur règlement
du Sénat comprennent bien qu'elle est la
conséquence de la décision du
gouvernement en accord avec la majorité
sénatoriale à partir de norean avant
nous n'allons discuter que les
amendements retenus par le gouvernement
nous serons tout à l'heure quand nous
aurons pu examiner la liste précise
combien d'amendements de l'opposition
des groupes de gauche ont été retenus
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y en ait
beaucoup ensuite nous allons discuter
des amendements probablement qui ont
convenu au gouvernement et à la majorité
sénatoriale et quand on dit souvent ses
amendements il y aura je le précise un
orateur pour c'est pas nous puisque on
présente pas l'amendement le rapport la
commission c'est pas nous parce que nous
ne sommes pas importants et ensuite le
gouvernement ce qui revient à dire que
sur tous les amendements que vous avez
retenus qui ne viennent pas de
l'opposition nous ne pourrons pas nous
exprimer c'est ça la procédure que vous
mettez en place alors vous ne pouvez pas
dire que ce n'est pas une procédure
bâillon vous avez décidé que la gauche
devait se taire jusqu'à la fin de ce
débat et puisqu'on parle de la fin de ce
débat puisqu'on parle de la fin de ce
débat il nous devions siéger jusqu'à
dimanche soir vous avez retenu 70
amendements ça peut aller très vite
visiblement votre intention c'est ça et
très vite et nous ne sommes que vendredi
midi il y avait encore deux journées et
demi complète de travail soit 3 6 8
séances 8 séances alors vous qui voulez
faire travailler des Français deux ans
de plus vous n'êtes pas capable de
travailler trois jours de plus c'est pas
glorieux
[Applaudissements]
comme la présidente Rossignol juste de
vous indiquer que tous les amendements
qui restent jusqu'à la fin de la
discussion seront présentés vous aurez
donc à présenter les amendements pas
seulement les amants qui viennent d'être
cités les amendements qui viennent
d'être cités par le ministre ont reçu un
avis pharoable mais l'ensemble des
amendements le petit millier qui reste
seront présentés je donne la parole pour
rappel au règlement au président à
Monsieur Hainaut
oui merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
tout au long de ces débats on
s'attendait bien à ce que vous vous
opposiez à ce texte et on en a pas été
surpris on avait vu au compteur un
certain nombre d'amendements mais la
question qui était posée c'était de
savoir si vous vouliez que dans le temps
qui était quand même compté plus de 120
heures de débats nous puissions nous
nous exprimer et voter et plusieurs fois
Roger caroutchi avec calme et
pondération a appelé les débats à
progresser à avancer
c'est étonnant et se demandant s'il y
avait pas une forme d'obstruction au
fond c'est toute la question bien sûr
qui a ce texte des retraites bien sûr
que vous avez le droit de vous y opposer
nous-même parfois on a des réserves sur
le calendrier sur la forme sur la
question du travail sur le sens du
travail et tout ça c'est le rôle du
Parlement mais le Parlement et c'est
même j'irai dire quelque chose qui
dépasse la réforme des retraites le
Parlement la démocratie représentative
elle doit parler débattre mais aussi
s'exprimer et c'est ça qui fait notre
clivage on n'est pas très heureux de
devoir utiliser une procédure comme
celle là mais pourquoi on fait ça
pourquoi on fait ça
on a parlé de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
quelquefois quelquefois je dis qui rôde
mais c'est pas ça que je vais vous dire
c'est pas ça que je vais vous dire c'est
pas ça que je vais vous dire au moins
lui il y a une différence avec vous
c'est qu'il a l'obstruction glorieuse et
vous vous avez l'obstruction honteuse et
c'est ça mes chers collègues qui depuis
le début est une forme d'hypocrisie vous
ne voulez pas vous exprimer mais vous
vous camouflez derrière des arguments de
procédure et cette obstruction honteuse
elle vous grandit pas et nous on veut
aller au bout de ce de ce texte pour le
Sénat pour la démocratie représentative
je vous remercie madame pense et mange
pour rappel au règlement madame
pansement pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente qu'est-ce qui
se joue avec ce 44,3 c'est que le
gouvernement la droite devient
e-libéral il libéral vous devenez
autoritaire et pourquoi ben tout
simplement parce que vous êtes
extrêmement minoritaire et quand on est
minoritaire qu'on veut imposer son point
de vue on devient inébaral vous avez usé
du triptyque bien connu provoquer
réaction répression vous nous avez
provoqué constamment ce matin quel était
le sens de la priorité de l'article
aucun ce que vous vouliez c'est qu'on
fasse des rappels au règlement donc vous
nous avez provoqué nous avons réagi et
maintenant vous nous réprimer en 68
c'était bien connu ça oui tout à fait
moi
personnellement je tiens à adresser un
message au mouvement social qui est
majoritaire et que le gouvernement
malgré cela veut passer en force oui
mais parce que j'explique rappelle au
règlement madame ponce non je ne peux
pas accepter donc je donne la parole à
Monsieur Fernique pour un rappel au
règlement en attendant
la Présidente chers collègues donc sur
la base de l'article
sur la base sur la base de l'article 42
9 de notre règlement qui dit comment se
passe les choses quand le gouvernement
dégaine le 44 3 de la Constitution je
crois qu'il faut bien qu'on prenne
conscience les autres que si ça se passe
ainsi ça signifie que nous n'aurons plus
qu'un seul vote
un seul sur l'ensemble du texte et sur
l'ensemble des amendements dont on nous
a donné oralement une liste et dont nous
attendons de pouvoir découvrir ce que
nous aurons au menu que nous aurons à
avaler d'un seul coup
d'elle clarté belle sincérité des débats
quand il n'y a que les pour qui
s'exprimeront car ça aussi il faut en
prendre conscience un seul vote mais
systématiquement un seul son de cloche
en trois temps en trois temps je le
concède il y a les auteurs de
l'amendement cela ils sont pour leur
amendement en principe
il y a la commission favorable à ses
amendements et il y a le gouvernement
dont j'ai l'impression qu'il sera
favorable aussi à ses amendements les
autres ce thèse ils écoutent c'est tout
alors je veux bien que que le décorum de
cette émission que notre salle des
conférences que notre palais du
Luxembourg
fasse un petit peu Second Empire c'est
clair mais que notre Sénat bascule dans
sa pratique vers un tel
bonapartiste non non
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues que
les amendements qui ont été élus par le
ministre ce sont ceux qui vont recevoir
un avis favorable
mais nous verrons tous les amendements
qui restent dans l'allias nous verrons
donc le petit millier d'amendements qui
nous reste dans la liasse ceux qui ont
été cités par le ministre sont ceux qui
ont un a priori favorable monsieur
Bocquet pour rappel au règlement
oui merci madame la Présidente
en vertu l'article 49-3 règlement
effectivement je voudrais d'abord donner
lecture de la ligne à 3 de l'article 44
de la Constitution sur lequel on est en
train de se prononcer les uns et les
autres je le cite si le gouvernement le
demande
l'assemblée saisie se prononce par un
seul vote sur tout ou partie du texte en
discussion on ne retenant que les
amendements proposés ou acceptés par le
gouvernement fin de citation
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire il y a
quelques jours ici que il n'y avait plus
au Sénat qu'un seul bloc libéral pour
soutenir cette réforme libérale il y a
un accord de fond on le sait ce n'est
pas une surprise mais là on est en train
d'assister à une forme de sabordage du
Sénat dans cette république il y avait
le BIC amerisme j'ai envie de parler à
l'imparfait malheureusement le Sénat
joue son rôle dans cette république mais
là on est en train de le saborder et où
est la séparation des pouvoirs dans
cette situation c'est gravissime ce qui
est en train de se passer le ministre
choisit les amendements publics
conviennent sincèrement ce moment est
grave je veux le dire avec solennité
après la crise économique qui sévit
depuis longtemps dans ce pays la crise
sociale qui est en train de s'exprimer
vous allez ajouter une fiche politique
majeure dans un pays fracturé et en
tension
monsieur chanterelle
madame madame la Présidente se rappelle
au règlement en vertu de l'article 44
bis de notre règlement intérieur
aujourd'hui vous piétinez le Sénat avec
la complicité de la droite sénateur
gouvernement est responsable de ce qui
se passe depuis le début en ayant choisi
justement l'utilisation du 47 ans qui
limite les débats qui n'ont pas permis
d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée nationale
d'aller au bout des débats et qui
brutalise à nouveau à travers
l'utilisation de cet article de la
Constitution 44-3 pour brutaliser le
Sénat vous avez une pratique du pouvoir
brutal vous prouvez à travers tous ces
artifices l'essoufflement de cette
république de cette cinquième république
aujourd'hui vous en faites à nouveau la
démonstration d'ailleurs
hasard du calendrier sort aujourd'hui un
livre intitulé une république
aboutsouffle que je vous recommande
justement de lire elle montre à quel
point les contradictions les archaïsmes
de cette constitution sa vulnérabilité
qui augmente face aux tentations
autoritaires et qu'un nouveau partage
des pouvoirs serait savateur pour une
république enfin sociale et écologie
mais face ce coup de force que vous
essayez de faire c'est un coup de force
contre les Françaises et les Françaises
qui se battent aussi contre cette
réforme c'est eux que vous brutalisez à
travers ces outils quand vous brutalisez
notre le Parlement c'est pour ça que
malgré tous ces artifices nous serons
nombreux nous appelons justement les
Françaises et les Françaises de se
mobiliser en masse encore plus nombreux
et nombreuses face à cette volonté de
nous brutaliser car samedi nous serons
avec eux dans la rue
finalement désormais les Français
à partir du moment où leur privé de
débat au sein du Parlement monsieur
kerouge vous demande de faire votre
appel au règlement en indiquant
l'article auquel vous faites référence
c'est Monsieur keroski là-bas à la
parole pour son rappel au règlement
monsieur Kerrouche sur quel fondement du
rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente
encore une remarque à notre collègue et
nos parce qu'il nous interpelle vous
êtes obsédé monsieur par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous faites une fixation il y
a de très bonnes consultations
psychologique en ce qui nous concerne en
ce qui nous concerne nous sommes
socialistes écologistes et communiste
bien
un bel exercice quand même commun de
médiocrité parlementaire parce que
vous nous expliquez l'ensemble des
mesures ou des dispositions que nous
aurions prises pour ne pas faire avancer
le débat ou pour faire obstruction ceci
étant je rappelle notamment pour le
Conseil constitutionnel que par exemple
il y a une collusion évidente entre la
commission des affaires sociales et sa
présidente et le gouvernement parce que
en ne réunissant pas la commission cela
permettait de mettre en place l'article
44 alinéa 2 c'est de la collusion
ensuite vous avez utilisé l'article 38
avec une seule prise de parole l'article
42 10 le temps déterminé l'article 44-6
sur les priorités l'article 46 bis 2 sur
les examens disjoints l'article 46 bis 4
dites-moi vraiment qui a fait de
l'obstruction parlementaire qui
en fait
en fait nous aurons eu avec ce débat la
preuve que cette réforme était mauvaise
je salue la présence de Franck Riester
qui le premier a manifester le fait que
cette réforme se faisait au détriment
des femmes et bien tout le long de
l'examen tout le long de l'examen nous
aurons montré que cette réforme est très
mauvaise et je terminerai par une
formule bien connue mais elle est
vraiment vérifiée aujourd'hui la
roche-tard Payenne n'est pas loin du
capital du Capitole pardon
je voyais monsieur carucci je voyais
monsieur carucci j'ai pensé à ça je suis
désolé mais très sérieusement le succès
que vous pensez avoir aujourd'hui et
déjà la défaite de demain
brûlant pour rappel
aux règles madame Brulin
merci madame la Présidente
je crois que le temps du débat c'est le
gouvernement qui la volontairement
réduit d'abord en soumettant l'examen de
ce texte à l'article 47 1 qui oblige à
finir ce débat dimanche minuit et qui
ensuite refusent d'ouvrir ce qui reste
possible le débat au-delà de dimanche
minuit il serait d'ailleurs peut-être
encore temps de le faire parce qu'il
reste un certain nombre d'amendements à
exposer et je pense que si vous vouliez
vraiment montrer que vous êtes prêt au
débat vous ouvrirez la séance au-delà de
dimanche la majorité sénatoriale ne
s'est en effet pas grandi de prêter le
flanc à toutes ces manœuvres elle s'est
réduite à une béquille du gouvernement
en se prenant les pieds dans le tapis
puisque toutes les procédures activées
depuis plusieurs jours maintenant n'ont
contribué qu'à une seule chose c'est à
retarder encore le débat et à ne pas
avancer sur l'examen du texte
je crois que ce vote bloqué vous
l'activez aussi parce que dans la
majorité sénatoriale comme dans la
majorité présidentielle les fractures et
les lézards se font de plus en plus
ouvertes ici je l'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire et je vais le redire 55 de nos
collègues qui appartiennent au bord de
la droite et du centre ont refusé de
voter l'article 7 c'est ça qui vous pose
problème je tiens c'est absolument leur
droit et nous les en félicitons ce qui
est en revanche irresponsable c'est que
à activer ce petit frère du 49-3 vous
allez redoubler la colère du pays et
c'est absolument irresponsable dans le
contexte où nous sommes pour ce qui nous
concerne nous allons continuer de
défendre argument après argument les
méfaits de cette réforme qui repousse
l'âge de la retraite de deux ans vous
pouvez compter sur nous nous ne
lâcherons pas sur chacun de nos
arguments
monsieur
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'avais vu
que le président rotaïo c'était
inscrivant moi j'espère que je lui passe
pas devant
vous avez perdu le débat politique
l'utilisation du 49-3 sénatorial c'est
la preuve que vous avez perdue le débat
politique vous avez d'abord accepté le
47 heures la procédure contrainte pour
les débats y compris vous avez un texte
qui a pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale puis ici après l'obstruction
silencieuse vous avez utilisé
l'obstruction réglementaire en allant
chercher ce bouquin au fin fond d'une
armoire poussiéreuse avec des arguments
et des règlements qui n'avaient jamais
utilisé été utilisé auparavant et je
vous le redis vous ne règlerez pas la
question politique par des argusies
réglementaires et maintenant vous vous
en remettez au gouvernement qui active
l'arme du 49-3 sénatorial pour mettre
fin
à nos débats mais le débat il continue à
l'extérieur des millions de travailleurs
et travailleuses se sont mis puissamment
en grève et celles et ceux qui nous
regardent qu'ils sachent une chose nous
continuerons à défendre nos arguments et
nos amendements jusqu'au bout vous allez
être contraint d'entendre tout ce que
nous voulions débattre et il faut
continuer à se mobiliser puissamment
samedi parce que nous voulons une chose
et nous ne céderons rien et les trois
groupes de gauche écologistes
socialistes et communiste resteront une
irrase
de cette réforme unique et chers
collègues vous êtes rentrés très fort et
majoritaire vous en sortez affaibli et
tout petit et si vous pensez que vous
allez régler la chose à 14 dans une
salle en CMP contre la majoritaire des
Français vous vous gourez merci
[Applaudissements]
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues d'abord je trouve que
franchement
j'écoutais madame borne qui nous
rappelait mercredi
elle a évoqué la séparation des pouvoirs
je suis assez scandalisé de la
proposition du missile du socle en
l'absence du président du Sénat
c'est un événement important pour notre
institution donc on choisit pas
on minimum on se respecte et je peux
d'autant plus me dire que vous le savez
mes collègues Hélène j'ai porte une
appréciation assez dure à l'encontre de
notre président à un moment donné de nos
débats avec vous me connaissez avec ma
sincérité s'agissant l'obstruction
monsieur Hainaut alors là franchement
ne portons pas des mots plus haut qu'on
n'a pas besoin d'invec ici personne n'a
avoir honte moi je vais vous dire des
145 LR des 145 élèves il y en a 127
qu'on peut convoité pour mais les autres
n'ont qu'une honte à avoir les
centristes et ses 50 157 INAC 35 ont
voté pour mais les autres n'ont pas de
honte à avoir les indépendants Républic
et territoires sont 24 22 ont voté pour
les deux autres n'ont pas de honte à
avoir et je peux continuer la liste
comme ça donc il n'y a pas eu
d'obstruction il n'y a pas eu
d'obstruction il y a des parlementaires
des sénatrices et des sénateurs qui ont
eu l'occasion d'exprimer des votes
contraires donc il n'y a pas eu
obstruction du débat vous n'avez pas
changer entrepris des éléments de votre
majorité c'est pas sérieux et puis après
là quand même on est dans un duo là
franchement c'est impressionnant on a un
article 7 qui est réécrit en duo en 10
minutes après on nous a fait l'article
38 moi je vais vous dire ce qui est en
train de se passer vous êtes en train de
créer un régime des pleins pouvoirs
voilà ce que vous êtes en train de faire
et vous et je le dis à la majorité
senoriale sénatoriale en acceptant le
diktak du gouvernement vous êtes en
train de faire de la béquille parce que
vous êtes en train de préparer un
nouveau régime parce qu'on est en train
d'affaiblir les deux assemblées le
pouvoir parlementaire et je vous dis ça
sans invective et sans polémique il y a
82 % de Français en colère ce matin
82% de français en colère ce matin
pour rappel au règlement
et madame la Présidente un rappel au
règlement en vertu de l'article 44 bis
personne n'éduque monsieur le ministre
chers collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale
votre pénible liste à la Prévert de
justification à votre décision de
piétiner l'opposition n'a rien à voir
avec la réalité de ce qui s'est passé
ici et avec la brutalité qui s'est
exprimée c'est vous monsieur le ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les collègues de
la majorité sénatoriale qui nous avait
muselé bâillonner
bâillonné embarrassé embarrassée que
vous êtes
par nos arguments et nos propositions en
opposition à votre réforme réactionnaire
et néfaste pour les Français
les Français n'y comprennent plus rien
mais il doit savoir que c'est un coup
d'État que vous venez de déclencher ici
au Sénat
et vous allez tristement aujourd'hui
marquer l'histoire
je n'y ai pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente au moins
trois articles 46 bits 44 bits 44 terre
je
à cet instant je constate que la
discussion a démarré avec un accord
politique légitime oui oui monsieur
carochi légitime entre la majorité
sénatoriale et le gouvernement sur le
fond d'un texte
vous nous avez donné l'habitude d'être
plus placide chers
et cet accord politique s'est transformé
et c'est là qu'elle problème en accord
institutionnel
la constitution de notre République elle
donne beaucoup de pouvoir à l'exécutif
plus que dans tout autre démocratie par
le mentale et le règlement du Sénat il
tente de préserver les droits de
l'institution parlementaire
l'activation du 49-3 fait partie des
prérogatives constitutionnelles du
gouvernement 44-3 pardon constitutionnel
du gouvernement le ministre choisit de
l'activer
mais là nous avons assisté à autre chose
nous avons assisté à une majorité
sénatoriale qui a organisé l'activation
de cet article avec le gouvernement
il en résulte
une confusion institutionnelle qui est
grave vous ne défendez plus le Sénat
vous utilisez les outils que notre
Constitution donne à l'exécutif pour
activer accélérer l'adoption d'un texte
au Sénat vous n'utilisez pas le fait
majoritaire là vous utilisez vous vous
pliez à une demande de gouvernement avec
les outils de l'exécutif et ça c'est
grave et ça c'est grave parce que je
comprends que le fait majoritaire vous
donne le droit de faire voter un texte
vous pouvez vous exclamer
comme nos droits d'opposants nous
donnent le droit d'accueiller les outils
pour le freiner mais là vous avez
franchi le Rubicon vous êtes mis dans la
main de l'exécutif
monsieur Breuillet pour rappel au
règlement
merci Madame madame
la Présidente au nom de l'article 42 9
et à propos de l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution
nous parlions au début de ces débats de
des traditionnels débats feutrés du
Sénat et nous allons terminer sur des
débats baïonnés la démocratie se mesure
au respect des minorités mais aussi des
syndicats des corps sociaux pour les
syndicats lorsqu'ils demandent à être
reçus par le Président de la République
la première ministre les renvoie dans le
bureau de Monsieur du soft
du respect je ne le sais pas sans
vouloir manquer de respect au ministre
je pense que l'ampleur de la
manifestation nécessitait que le
président l'ai reçu en ce qui nous
concerne après le choix d'un véhicule
législatif qui contraint nos débats et
qui nous oblige à terminer dans les
délais contraints fixés par l'article
47.1 pour voter vite trop vite cette
mauvaise réforme avec votre accord et la
chair collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale voilà donc le 44 3 utilisé
pour bâillonner c'est le mot
l'opposition sénatoriale et hélas je le
dis avec la complicité de la majorité
sénatoriale je suis tout récent ici j'ai
toujours vu les sénateurs bataillés pour
le respect de leurs droits et de la
capacité d'agir et de débattre du
Parlement
et si cette capacité est mise à mal
après que reste-t-il que reste-t-il
chers collègues lorsque les
manifestations sont méprisées monsieur
le ministre que reste-t-il quel article
de la Constitution permet de bâillonner
des millions de manifestants et vers
quel régime allons-nous aller
pour rappel au règlement pardon monsieur
Dantec
oui merci madame la présidente rappelle
au règlement évidemment sur la base du
44 bijou je voudrais vous relire
l'article 28 le Premier ministre après
consultation du président de l'assemblée
concernée ou la majorité des membres de
chaque assemblée peut décider la tenue
de jour supplémentaire de séance avec le
47 ans nous avons 50 jours nous pouvons
donc aller plus tard que dimanche si
vous vouliez vraiment que nous débâtions
vous aviez la possibilité par la
constitution de rajouter des jours et
c'est ce que j'ai d'ailleurs proposé
hier soir simplement vous ne le voulez
pas et ce matin vous avez même multiplié
les
provocations y compris pour se faire
tomber 10 ou amendements pour justement
arriver à ce que vous aviez décidé
depuis déjà longtemps je crois
qu'effectivement ça a été dit par mes
collègues c'est un affaiblissement
terrible du Parlement c'est un
affaiblissement du Sénat avec le soutien
de la majorité sénatoriale et je vais
pas être très très long
ça parlera aux quelques gaullistes qui
sont encore sur les bandes droites je
crois que le titre de ce qui se passe ce
matin c'est balle tragique au Sénat un
mort la société française qui sort plus
fragilisée que jamais
monsieur Pacaud pour rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente merci en vertu de
l'article 44 alors on a entendu des mots
quand même assez fort le président
Kanner a parlé de réactionnaire
notre ami salvaudélie a parlé des pleins
pouvoirs les pleins pouvoirs ils ont été
votés à Pétain en juillet 40 c'est quand
même une référence navrante on a parlé
de bonapartisme ce n'est pas le 18
brumaire le ministre du socle n'est pas
Joachim Murat il n'y a pas de grenadier
pour vous sortir d'ici
vous avez parlé
il n'y a qu'un seul regret c'est que
nous soyons contraints de subir ce que
vous appelez un 49-3 sénatorial nous
aurions tous aimé vous comme nous mais
peut-être pas avec la même sincérité
aller jusqu'au bout du vrai débat cette
espèce de 49-3 sénatorial il est
provoqué il est provoqué il faut que
vous l'assumiez par votre coagulation
des débats votre attitude aboutissait à
une embolie sénatoriale et je suis navré
de conclure en utilisant la morale du
rat et de l'huître de la Fontaine tel
est pris qui croyait prendre
monsieur ozoulias pour rappel au
règlement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres mais mes chers collègues les
Français et les Françaises nous
regardent et ne comprennent qu'une seule
chose face à cette émission les
républicains du Sénat sont entrés au
gouvernement voilà ce que les Français
comprennent aujourd'hui nous sommes face
à une crise politique majeure majeur
l'autorité du Président de la République
est en question l'autorité de la
première ministre étant question le
groupe majoritaire de l'Assemblée
nationale a éclaté il ne reste plus
qu'au gouvernement l'assurance de
pouvoir disposer des votes du groupe
républicain au Sénat chers collègues je
vous pose la question est-ce que vous
allez sauver le quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron
monsieur dessus pour rappel au règlement
ce qu'elle fondement monsieur dessus
on va remettre un peu de contexte parce
que j'entends un peu n'importe quoi qui
a raconté sur les rangs de la droite
qui réécrit qui réécrit largement
l'histoire de ce débat qui réécrit
largement l'histoire de ce débat on a eu
un débat sur un jusqu'à mardi à peu près
on a étudié jusqu'à 6 articles
sereinement ça a été long évidemment
mais on a étudié six articles
sereinement jusqu'à mardi mardi il s'est
passé quelque chose les Françaises sont
levés ils sont ils vous ont dit à quel
point ils rejetaient cette réforme les
grèves ont commencé à se mettre en place
et là ça a été le début de la panique
début de la panique c'est 1000
amendements de la gauche qui sont tombés
pour un effet de procédure ensuite ça a
été la montée en puissance du règlement
42 38 44 de hier mais aussi les débuts
de la fissure on a vu certains de des
sénateurs de droite et du centre qui ne
votaient pas l'article 7
on a vu aussi qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
les menaces commencaient à pleuvoir sur
les les députés de la majorité qui ne
voteraient pas ce texte aujourd'hui pour
12 sous amendements 12 sous amendements
c'est une demi-heure de débats 12 sous
amendements le ministre a craqué il a
sorti le 44 3
il nous reste 900 amendements 900
amendements
oui allez 1000 1000
1000 sous amendements il nous restait
trois jours de débat on aurait même plus
ouvrir une journée de plus on aurait pu
aller au bout c'était les débats sur le
sucré de la réforme sur les meneurs
d'athénomation de la brutalité de la
réforme mon avis hier quand on a
commencé à les débattre qu'on avait même
plus à les expliquer ici que personne ne
comprenait que c'est que ces mesures
d'atténuations n'étaient pas à la
hauteur donc on la revient on vient de
comprendre ce qui se passe c'est à dire
que vous n'arrivez pas à masquer la
brutalité de la réforme vous arrivez
plus à l'assumer ces débats et donc vous
essayez de nous faire taire tout le
monde l'a compris mais vous n'y
arriverez pas et demain les versions
seront massives monsieur Tissot pour
rappel au règlement
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mon rappel
au règlement sera sur la base de
l'article 42 alinéa 9 de notre règlement
alors que l'avenir des Françaises et les
Français est en jeu et que nous
débattuons du droit à avoir une retraite
en bonne santé et un repos mérité après
de longues carrière érintantes je suis
profondément choqué par le contournement
du Parlement et du débat démocratique
décidé par le gouvernement en seulement
30 minutes chers collègues de la
majorité
sénatorial en acceptant la proposition
du gouvernement prenez vous conscience
de ce que vous venez d'accepter alors
que vous cessez vous ne cessez de
rappeler la grandeur du Sénat à laquelle
je crois vous venez de réduire au néant
son rôle institutionnel au sein de notre
République
je souhaitais revenir sur les propos de
notre collègue qui parlaient
d'obstructions honteuses des groupes de
gauche et vous mon cher collègue
n'avez-vous pas honte de refuser un
débat sur un texte qui privera les
Français de deux ans de vie et de
projets à accomplir
moi j'aime bien quand la droite
manifeste quand je parle parce que ça
veut dire que moi en tant que lutte
gauche je touche juste
monsieur du soft monsieur le ministre
vous justifiez cette manœuvre de
contournement pour faire aboutir un
texte de loi
soi-disant de justice sociale pourtant
mardi dernier plus de 6000 personnes
étaient réunies dans une ville que vous
connaissez bien à nose commune vous avez
été maire député de cette
circonscription commune qui joue
extrêmement département de nombreux
manifestement rappelaient qu'il y a 12
ans vous manifestiez alors côté contre
la réforme des retraites d'Eric worth en
dénonçant et ce sont vos mots de
l'époque une réforme doublement injuste
pensez-vous cette fois que votre réforme
est juste monsieur le ministre je pense
que l'ensemble des interventions que
nous avons plus sur le rappel aux
règlements monsieur le colis
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la Présidente je souhaitais finalement
réagir à quelques-uns des rappels au
règlement sur un point en particulier
mais monsieur Tissot évoquant une
commune qui m'est cher m'invite
finalement à réagir plus vite encore que
ce que je le pensais je dis ça vous avez
évoqué la manifestation qui s'est
déroulée dans ma commune celle où
j'habite et ça me permet d'apporter un
élément nouveau et je le dis en
précisant que aucun destinateur ici
présent n'est responsable de cela
j'ai indiqué il y a quelques heures de
débat maintenant peut-être deux jours
que de 10h à 15h 2400 foyers de ma
commune avait été privé d'électricité
après une coupure volontaire
cette coupure volontaire a entraîné la
nécessité pour les lycées de fermer
leurs portes à empêcher les commerçants
de travailler à nécessité que les
pompiers interviennent pour débloquer
délivrer plus exactement des personnes
bloquées dans des ascenseurs à contraint
les résidents d'un foyer de personnes
âgées à manger froid et des
interventions de pompiers pour des
personnes placées sous respirateur et à
causer le désordre que vous imaginez
cette coupure volontaire monsieur
monsieur le sénateur a été depuis
revendiqué par la CGT énergie si c'est
de ce mouvement social dont vous
réclamez je ne suis pas sûr que ça
participe à la clarté ou la légitimité
des débats
ensuite
j'ai entendu à plusieurs reprises des
mots qui je crois dépassent largement le
cadre de nos débats
j'ai entendu et les rappels éducats des
rappels de règlement mais monsieur le
Président carochine n'étant pas moi-même
sénateur je n'ose me prononcer sur cet
aspect là sur les mots que j'ai entendus
coup de force bâillon censure régime et
libéral il démocratique coup d'État
régime autoritaire je crois
véritablement que ça n'est pas
nécessairement adéquate lorsqu'on mette
en œuvre une procédure prévue par la
Constitution par notre texte principal
par des dispositions qui autorisent le
gouvernement à solliciter du Parlement
une seule chose c'est la clarté
d'impositionnement et d'un débat j'ai
aussi entendu des discours ou des
interventions offusqués disant mais
finalement que faites-vous personne n'a
jamais osé faire cela c'est absolument
incroyable
les quelques rappels qui se sont
succédés m'ont permis de consulter les
archives du Sénat le 20 avril 2013 après
18h de débats après l'examen de 156
amendements sur les 679 qui étaient
déposés sur le projet de loi relatif à
la sécurisation professionnelle
qui comptait 20 articles c'est le hasard
de la comparaison un de mes
prédécesseurs Michel Sapin
avait recours à l'article 44.2
considérant qu'il n'y avait pas de
possibilité autre pour faire aboutir le
texte et c'est d'autant plus particulier
que le gouvernement qu'il représentait à
l'époque au bon
44,3 vous avez raison article 44 3
gouvernement que je soutenais j'ai voté
la loi à l'Assemblée nationale mais le
gouvernement auquel participé monsieur
sapin pour porter cette ce projet de loi
en 2013 et pour lequel il a utilisé
l'article 44-3 était majoritaire dans
cet assemblée c'est la démonstration
mais que même lorsqu'un gouvernement est
majoritaire dans une assemblée s'il fait
face à l'obstruction il a recours à des
dispositions constitutionnelles pour
permettre l'expression de la clarté des
débats de l'Assemblée
monsieur le président karucci pour
rappel au règlement
sur la base madame la Présidente de
l'article 46 bis je voudrais premier
élément parce que en fait bon c'est vrai
que le débat était contraint par le 47
ans mais je voudrais juste dire
puisqu'il y a eu dans un des rappels
règlement que le gouvernement est très
bien pu laisser un jour de plus sur la
base de l'article 28 bête c'est faux
mais c'est faux pardon de vous le dire
parce que l'article 28 dit il y a 120
jours possible dans une session
ordinaire et le gouvernement peut
rajouter une journée pour faire 121 122
le cas échéant et ça n'a rien à voir
avec le 47 ans qui lui fixe très
clairement le nombre et là-dessus vous
ne pouvez rien rajouter donc c'est
totalement non mais pardon on peut
tordre le cou à la Constitution mais
tout mais ce que j'entends ici me désole
pourquoi parce que un coup on remet en
cause le règlement du Sénat qui je le
rappelle a été adopté à l'unanimité de
tous les groupes en 2015 un coup on
remet en cause des articles de la
Constitution
aussi date de 1958 en tout cas pour les
articles concernés le 44.2 ou le 44,3
aucun gouvernement de gauche depuis 1958
n'a modifié la constitution de ce côté
là aucun parce que chacun des
gouvernements a considéré qu'il fallait
évidemment avoir une capacité de passer
outre à l'obstruction gouvernement de
gauche gouvernement de droite
gouvernement Macron personne n'a
envisagé même dans les idées de réforme
qui viennent aujourd'hui personne ne
remet en cause l'article 44 c'est quand
même un peu un problème non mais écoutez
merci Monsieur Savoldelli mais la vérité
c'est que quand j'entends coup d'État
quand j'entends je ne sais quoi nous
essayons nous essayons de débattre à
plusieurs reprises j'ai demandé pour la
sérénité des débats qu'on arrête les
sous amendements qu'on arrête les
explications multiples pour rentrer dans
le fond dans le respect de tous ça n'a
pas été possible vous portez la
responsabilité vous portez la
responsabilité du fait qu'aujourd'hui le
débat parlementaire doivent céder le pas
malheureusement à une méthode plus
autoritaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le Président retailleux pour
rappel aux règlements pour un rappel au
règlement mes chers collègues de gauche
vous surjouez le 46 bis
vous surjouez l'indignation
chers collègues de gauche et vous faites
mine d'être surpris mais vous ne l'êtes
pas
l'application du vote bloqué c'est la
Constitution
ça n'est pas une application il libérale
de notre loi fondamentale ici nous
sommes sur la 5e République nous ne
sommes pas sous la Quatrième République
l'application du vote bloqué
la cause c'est vous c'est votre
obstruction vous avez donné votre
version des faits je vous donne notre
version des faits bien sûr jusqu'à mardi
7 mars tout se passait bien puisque nous
avions un engagement vous souhaitiez
discuter et que l'on vote l'article 7
pas avant le 7 nous nous sommes tu pas
bâillonner nous nous sommes tu pour
respecter notre engagement et ensuite
vous n'avez tenu aucun de vos
engagements très vite nous sommes
aperçus que vous vouliez nous empêcher
d'aller au bout de débattre du fond et
de voter le texte
l'obstruction c'est quand on dépose
449 demandes de rapport l'obstruction
c'est quand on multiplie des amendement
identique des sous amendements ridicules
qui n'apportent rien des rappels au
règlement qui n'en sont pas ça c'est de
l'obstruction et l'obstruction
finalement c'est la négation du rôle du
Parlement vous transformez le Sénat en
un groupe de parole le Parlement ne vaut
bien sûr qu'avec les débats pour
éclairer la délibération et le vote
c'est notre métier c'est notre devoir le
devoir que nous avons pris par rapport
aux Français mes chers collègues et on
ne peut pas dans une enceinte
parlementaire on ne peut pas supporter
qu'une minorité prenne en otage une
majorité par le seul fait par le seul
fait que vous ne vouliez pas
être perdant nous voulons voter et je
vous rappelle rapidement qu'au Sénat la
gauche à utiliser neuf fois le vote
bloqué et qu'elle Assemblée nationale
sur la loi Touraine c'était aussi cette
application madame la Présidente de
roche
très rapidement madame la Présidente moi
je voulais répondre à Renan Dantec sa
référence au bal tragique à Collombey en
mettant maintenant balle tragique au
Sénat et bien moi aujourd'hui je pense
aux familles des 146 personnes des
jeunes qui sont décédées dans le dancing
de l'Isère et si ça vous a fait rire
nous ça nous ne fait pas
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président malgré pour rappel
aux règlements
[Musique]
oh là là là là
la gauche morale et furieuse
la gauche morale est en colère
vous savez la gauche morale celle qui
nous dit faites ce que je vous dis mais
ne faites pas ce que je fais
la gauche morale qui nous dit comme le
rappeler monsieur le ministre tout à
l'heure
nous sommes scandalisés que vous
utilisez le 44 3 alors qu'elle a
allègrement utilisé lors du vote de la
loi Touraine
la gauche morale qui nous dit c'est très
démocratique de déposer 50 amendements
sur chaque article et de faire 20
explications de vote pour chacun d'eux
mais que ce n'est pas démocratique
d'adopter une procédure destinée à
couper court à ce qui n'est même plus
une obstruction mais une tentative de
destruction de la procédure
parlementaire
nous avions
nous avions un point d'accord au début
de l'examen de cette loi
celle de ne pas donner le lamentable
spectacle de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est terminé depuis longtemps
il y avait une jade à l'Assemblée
nationale
une zone à délirer des mélanges
qui n'ont toujours pas compris que
l'assemblée n'est pas une âgée de
lunaire il y a depuis une semaine au
Sénat une autre jade s'il vous plaît la
zone
[Musique]
qui poursuit exactement le même but
c'est à dire d'organiser l'impuissance
du Parlement en l'empêchant d'aboutir à
ce qui est son rôle essentiel le vote de
la loi et bien nous allons faire en
sorte que le Sénat fasse le boulot pour
lequel nous ont élus les Français nous
allons nous donner les moyens de voter
cette loi
monsieur canard monsieur le Président
canard monsieur le Président Gautard
vous avez demandé une suspension donc je
vous donne 5 minutes de suspension et
nous reprendrons pour consulter la
séance est suspendue
mes chers collègues la séance est
reprise
monsieur canner pour un rappel au
règlement
et nous reprendrons les amendements en
suivant
ça va bien se passer
madame la Présidente sur la base de
l'article 29 alinéa 2 du règlement
intérieur et au nom de mes collègues
gontards et assassis nous demandons
solennellement donc la réunion d'une
conférence des présidents sur l'ordre du
jour suivant conséquence de la mise en
oeuvre de l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution sur le bon déroulement de
nos débats
monsieur le Président je vais
transmettre au président du Sénat le
temps que vous formalisiez par écrit
votre votre demande bien écoutez je
transmets pour ma part je donne la
parole à Madame A pour ce poli pour
rappel au règlement
oui
règlement donc je prends je vais vous
faire rappel au règlement
depuis mardi passé vous en rêvez
depuis mardi passé vous en rêvez votre
rêve devient réalité après un mutisme
scandaleux vous êtes complice depuis le
début du gouvernement vous mettez
aujourd'hui un genou supplémentaire à
terre messieurs et mesdames de la droite
sénatoriale en acceptant ce 44,3 du
Sénat qui s'apparente au 49.3 de
l'Assemblée nationale vous bafouez la
démocratie nous sommes dans une
situation inédite ici ce matin au Sénat
c'est du jamais vu nous avons assisté
depuis plusieurs jours un simulacre
démocratie à diverses reprises à
diverses reprises à diverses reprises
nous vous avons demandé de réunir la
commission des affaires sociales pour
étudier nos sous-amendements vous
jamais jamais répondu à cette demande
mais vous pouvez compter sur nous pour
défendre Anna nos amendements parce
qu'ils parlent de la vie des gens des
ouvriers des salariés qui travaillent
dans des conditions difficiles de ceux
et de celle que vous avez décidé
gouvernement et majorité sénateuriales
de faire travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
la majorité n'est pas ici elle est dans
la rue la majorité plus de 4%
il voulait faire en payer alors
monsieur le président Gérard Larcher me
confirme qu'il y aura une conférence des
présidents à 14h ce que je vous propose
c'est que nous reprenions la suite des
amendements puisque toute manière à un
moment nous reprendrons donc conférence
des présidents à 14h et là je donne la
parole pour la demande 308
ah oui mais vous avez écouté c'était sur
le rappel aux règlements non moi je
souhaiterais je souhaiterais monsieur
Assouline qu'on puisse reprendre
il n'y a aucune raison j'en appelle j'en
appelle à votre sagesse pour que l'on
puisse reprendre les amendements nous
aurons la Conférence des présidents à 14
ans où chacun pourra se syndiquer
monsieur Assouline pour rappel au
règlement
merci pour votre merci pour votre grande
sagesse madame la Présidente
donc vous justifiez ce matin
ce que on en aurait pas
vous justifier ce matin
[Applaudissements]
en
quel article je l'ai dit à Madame quand
j'ai demandé à Madame la prison j'ai dit
pour 44 bis donc j'aimerais que commence
mon intervention maintenant on m'a
enlevé 20 secondes
[Applaudissements]
ce matin donc ce qui était annoncé par
bruit dans la presse
le fait d'écouter les débats et de les
écourter encore plus que prévu parce que
ils étaient écourtés avec ce que le
gouvernement avait décidé de nous
contraindre à finir dimanche soir
certains veulent vraiment partir en
week-end et avoir leur samedi et
dimanche mais nous jugeons nos jugeons
que l'affaire est grave vous pouvez nous
citer les moments où ces articles de la
Constitution ou du règlement ont été
déjà utilisés mais l'irresponsabilité
vient de quoi c'est que rarement nous
avons discuté du noir rejeté par toutes
les enquêtes d'opinions tous les trois
jours depuis deux mois par plus de deux
tiers des Français
nous n'avons jamais eu à faire à
écourter de cette façon les débats qu'en
3 millions et demi
de nos concitoyens manifestent et
répètent qui ne veulent pas de cette
réforme alors le minimum c'est que quand
nous discutons des carrières longues
quand nous discutons de l'article 7 qui
est l'article phare vous ne fassiez pas
tomber des centaines et des milliers
d'amendements nous avons riposté avec
une minorité peut avoir dans un
parlement en termes de Procédure à vos
coups de force bien entendu qu'on ne
plie pas le genou vous appelez ça de
l'obstruction mais vous avez oublié que
les sénateurs de gauche sont des
combattants nous combattons cette
réforme et on ne se laissera pas museler
souligne votre temps voilà est fini
merci puisque vous ne souhaitez pas que
nous reprenions les débats par
amendement je vais donc suspendre la
séance nous nous retrouverons à 14h30 à
cet après-midi bon appétit chers